That's what I got told yesterday.
It does one more.
Wait, when did they add that?
I got a fact check that.
One second.
17.
I'm holding in the range.
You don't believe it.
Versus 16.
Yeah, Versus 16.
Auto does 17.
I just tested it.
I did not know that.
When did they do that?
That's why.
That's why auto is so good close range.
Like you instacil on auto.
It's actually broken.
Okay, I didn't know that at all.
That's why.
Like you always want to run the stock.
I feel like I always want to run the stock on the prowler.
You have mags, dude.
Yeah, because you have such a big mag when you have purple.
doesn't even matter like you're losing bullets you don't
really need them on the pro i see that's true nice your your
strafe seat is so fast with the stock on the pro it's
actually insane yeah it's literally already 45 basically
guys i'm so locked in like you're never gonna get one cut
earlier guys i'm ready i'm so ready i apparently i was
giving a speed run on i was doki on the and you put on auto
the recoil is going to be very oh okay so for prowler it's
red laser because i know you can only have one red right
yeah one red if you have the laser on it gives you a lot
more recoil for every gun i see i see it's very hard to it's
very hard to like control out because it makes it pretty
much never want to use the red laser okay let's use him on
b20s yeah every other gun that's a negative all right we got
this guys four matches four games what is it top 10 top 10
yeah top apparently it's the teams are split to okay
apparently it's five teams get dq'd per per group because
there's 30 teams so i hope to god we're not those five we'll
be good we'll be good i've been up for like a bit but okay
we're so locked i'm still locked i'm still locked i play
controller if i was mnk player and i was up this longer it
would be over but all right cool cool you have your yeah the
roller can aim for you don't have to think about it exactly
it takes a nose girl yeah zero it aims for me i could just
close my eyes all right guys i'll talk guys okay so yes i'm
back from technically i'm back from vacation i am um and oh
is someone's mic echoing i think it's mac i think it's
albert la um so long story i know some some guys who don't
follow me on twitch might have been like back dokey i've
been back for two days technically i've been streamed i
streamed two streams on twitch uh one was for the rival's
tournament and the other one was for uh the sponsor and also
pal world so i'll tell you guys the full vacation um when
i'm back home i'm back i'm back but i'm not at my home i i
never i i'm i'm at a home guys i'm at a home right now
because i had to find a place that was closer yeah than
where i live so i can make it in time for the sponsor stream
i another one is like i know i'm playable yeah yeah it's
really bad
so um i had to make it in time for the sponsor stream but if
i had to fly back to my home i would not make it so i i had
to fly in a midway section so i could make it it was a
midway point between bahama by the way for those who don't
follow my twitter i was vacationing in the bahamas so i had
to find a midway point between the bahamas and where i live
so to make it because to Literally, I arrived to the
airport, and then I got a message for the arrival of the
stream, and it screams in an hour, and I was like, thank
God, thank God I did not, I did not fly straight home,
because I would not have made it to the sponsor, because I
was, like, so confused with, I was so confused with time
zones and everything.
All the time zones stuff was, like, fucking with my head.
so anyway now we're at we're eight came back from vacation
sponsored tournament tournament let's fast turkey knows
what's up fast turkey knows how to party you had a good
vacation damn you ready to have an even better work day it
was worth it was so worth it though it was oh my god i had a
great tab okay they say prowler i have to practice prowler
again it's been a while since i played with okay laser sight
um but yeah apparently it's top three worst patches in apex
so i'm about to see why the top three worst patches oh man
you should use 2x for it it was more beautiful oh i thought
i thought i might be able to choose beautiful oh i thought i
thought I was like, I was talking to me.
That's my voice.
The voice is in my head.
I just thought it was the voice is in my head right now.
I don't know how bad it is.
I just know it's like, I was told it was top three.
Okay.
I don't know.
That's what the pros are telling me.
Don't know what they did.
Not gonna lie.
wait you said there's 30 teams there there should be 30
teams yeah wait so we're playing 15 team lobbies yeah yeah
that's what i'm saying that's why i'm saying top 10 if we
are the the 10 people or five people that get knocked out
man don't jinx us i've done jinx us and then but hey we get
to clock out early though
to work yeah it's okay hey yeah let's look at the rules yeah
i'm not gonna lie i didn't not really read anything i don't
think i ever i don't think i'm ever the one that reads
something it's actually bad it doesn't even say it honestly
maybe it's just drop ship surely not um there will be And
Carrick Legends, picked by the most teams in that match,
we're going to put in the pool.
Teams must reach.
Oh, my gosh.
I've never played Match Point, but all right, let's go.
No, Match Point's fun.
So 50 points.
Once you touch 50 points, you have to win the game.
That's the one that we're doing.
And Alba's filling it to that.
I can already tell.
Oh, shit.
Today's the day we're going to win the Match Point finals,
Mac.
Today's...
How do you get to experience what that's like?
We still have an upgrade to choose.
But he doesn't say it.
Code's out, apparently.
Yeah?
Okay, hold up.
Yeah, lobby out and code out.
All right.
I don't see it anywhere.
I'm not going to lie.
They said it would be...
Oh, is it going to be on the battle fight?
It might be on the battle fight, yeah.
Yeah, it's on the battle fight, yeah.
Did they lie?
Spreading misinformation?
Yeah, it has nothing.
It just has not started.
How the fuck am I supposed to know which group I'm in?
wait i don't even know where to go did i join on my wrong
battle fight account i think i had two on accident i said
tournament is uh tournament is four games uh for a qual and
if you qual is smash port so we could be here the thing is
it's a little awkward because um um um ben you guys know ben
from like when my play was sure for gully and ben asked me
to play long walk was called the big fucking i don't know
the walking game today too and i was like i can do it after
the tournament and then they're like wins after tournament i
was like maybe three to four hours and now that i find out
that's matchpoint finals i'm i hope it's three to four hours
i hope i hope it's three to four hours uh you click on the
thing on the top left this is view lobby infinite or top
right If you lobby information.
Oh, I see, I see.
Yeah, it would be under bracket info.
Ah, yeah, just send me the code.
I can't.
I don't know what I'm doing.
Team name plat chat.
Yeah, that's me.
We're here to represent the plat players in our chat.
I like that.
See, I was plat for about like four seasons, so that's fair.
Yeah, we're here to represent them.
We're the people.
So we have to win it for the plots.
we got to win it for them you know yes let's do it let's see
who's in our lobby the goop gang denial crook bronzy that's
a pretty good team that's what i'm seeing oh is that the
three pro roster you're talking about yeah there's a couple
of them there's a couple of them not just they're not the
only ones that cheese the system i thought i cheese the
system too
they're like oh it's all right they're pro as long as they
didn't play rake the last two seasons now we look you have
the best team in this lobby yeah i don't see any that are
like crazy bronzes maybe maybe sauce's team what team is
that as long as we're not bottom five you know that's that's
that's where we're at is a good one too
a goop gang i like that that's a good name
yeah we should be fine the thing is they even have like a
logo they do they're they're locked on the battlefield i
don't even know you do that no i should have put a little
plot we should have put a little plastic oh that's true wait
i can do you think i can still edit it i don't i don't even
know i don't know how this this website works at all excuse
me too i'm not gonna lie me too a bit confusing sometimes oh
so that's how you view the lobby thing i see now i'm
figuring this out as we go along the fuck is in group two
does the group two come in with like because like two teams
are not confirmed do they just get like like less teams in
group two how
many teams in the group two there's there's two groups two
groups of 15 okay but then like we have only 28 teams sign
up so or checked it yeah literally 28 teams sign up so i'm
like wondering is is the second one's about to auto call the
finals basically yeah auto call in the other group put us in
group two bro
actually map the swap group two is about like 12 teams or
it's gonna be like 15 yeah bro honestly just move one of
teams over the group too at least ill like equalize it a
little yeah they probably should do that and then they're
just going off with like battlefly like they don't want too
much coding this shit yeah they probably already have it
like set up
bro how is phony not funny he's comedy bro he's saying uh he
said some of you motherfuckers need to pick actual platin
pred player like what is he saying bro this guy's just
coping this guy has a assault was a pred player oh shit i
should have wait Is everybody here?
Phony, not everybody's here.
Wait, I should change my badges.
I have a plaid badge on.
It can be a set.
You got plaid badges on?
All right, let me change.
I got to put plaid.
Yeah, I'm going to put plaid badges on real quick.
Let me get my plaid.
I'll be like, I don't know what you're talking about.
My badges are on plaid.
Yeah, you just say you've never hit it.
It's all good.
There you go.
I got it.
What season were you prepping?
Um, it was like the, for the season three and four.
oh and then i you know when you get it and and i got it and
i was like i made it i don't care anymore i abandoned the
game and never came back that's not true i came back i came
back every like right now every couple often i'd be like
what's going on in apex you know like hey but that's how it
goes you hit pred you just don't have anything else to play
for exactly it's like i'm not good enough for pro what the
fuck i make more money being a content so it's like so it's
like I don't need to go go any further yeah hit a rank 1
grand that is not worth 20 hours of apex rank today Ricky
come on lock in I heard it's like 5 years on your life yeah
like I heard about that because like I you like basically
sleep like 1 to 2 hours every day just to keep up with the
non-stop grind um yeah that seems that shit seems fucking
rough as hell but then like when you get the money from
streaming all of that it's like you're basically sort of
like semi set or some shit right no not anymore not anymore
it used to be back then back then it was crazy yeah back
then it's crazy back in the day i could get you like 4k plus
viewers concurrent of the nowadays like you can be ranked
one and it's still like 200 300 viewers really i guess this
game's out for a while now Like people just don't care about
ranked anymore.
Because it's just, everyone, everyone just knows that it's
just a time sink.
You just play 20 hours.
Because back then, every, like, back then, it's like, all
the pros were on too during those Grimes.
Yeah.
No one grinds really like that anymore.
And then the pros really care.
I also feel like during, like, COVID times and stuff,
there's a lot more Twitch.
That's true.
Yeah, there was.
So I feel like a lot more people just had a lot more time to
just watch stuff.
but like the first week of rank running you literally play
24 hours sleep four 20 like another 20 like it's like
actually bad yeah if you're actually trying to get just top
like literally just rank one i mean i'm top five so it's so
rough that's what i was doing when i but i was like 17 when
i was when i got rank one so i just like didn't care oh you
did you got rank one how much is yeah season season 15 i
literally played like two thousand and a hundred games in
one split holy how is it like did you actually get one hour
sleep per day for it like no no no no like the first like
two week or two i was getting like four hours but then after
after you get like a lead and stuff you can start sleeping a
lot more oh i mean that that makes sense yeah that's smart
but i was getting like like 800 viewers at the time well it
went downhill from there because you're not rank one anymore
i that after that rank one grind i did not want to play the
game ever again so it's not It's not gonna be stream sniped
by like cheaters a lot too when you're doing it I was
actually competing and is his Watson was going for rank one
too at the time Oh so they're all sniping him yeah yeah
there is also a cheater that was ranked rank one like that
we swapped him to be his Watson and this cheater we kept
swapping Harvester I think it's going to be horrible yeah
Doki Doki play some Watson oh Watson all right where is she
where is she oh there she Yeah, I see her.
What do you see?
Funk, get on, play some altar.
Oh, you're playing hard comp meta.
Oh, let's go.
I gotta put my skin on.
That's my skin right there.
You could have played some Gibby Bloodhound Axel.
If we get a real POI next to him, we will.
But this one, we're gonna be fucking...
No, but I actually think it's so bad against here.
I don't know if you're gonna win.
Oh, shit.
I forgot to change my badges.
Look at this one.
It's all good.
They're going to be scared now.
They're going to be like, oh, pause the flat plate.
Land on my yellow ring.
All the way around there.
Oh my god.
All right.
Move ring all the way around.
All the way over there?
Yeah, you loot the snake and then you'll hit your ring
console on the way out.
Oh, on the way out.
Or you can hit it now.
Yeah, I was going to say it.
Might as well.
Yeah.
I could have jumped on the crypto.
Oh, look, you feeling it.
I'm not putting you on crypto.
The crypto day would seem liquid.
Oh, hell no.
What do you mean?
I have a 10 bullet wingman.
I'm not in that team right now.
Well, my last team is liquid.
I'm back.
All right, let's get going.
All right, so now I get what you mean now when you say it's
like King's Canyon, i just i found one gun in the snake area
it's not idea we'll try to strap the three monument on our
way out sniper arsenal there but it's not going to come up
for like 20 seconds yeah we'll just go monument all right
i'm recalling my drone bigmont has no beacon so they're
going to come this way maybe yeah probably probably damn i
did not oh my gosh experiencing the the loot here it's rough
yeah it is bad where it's like going i'm gonna grab this
hard run i got an evil harvester here all right it just says
hand money or freggies
just path towards uh you're here all right yeah i'm back
blocked off my drone no level up would be complete with i
get the ultimate conductor or the help is here support
support right um yeah the support perk oh is the ultimate
conductor no no the other one okay it's shaped like a pill
okay like a bin that you have them yeah you're like right
and i was like that's not the support bin where they're
evaking in front of us might be able to kill one off those
oh one's late one's late yeah shoot i'm taking it out where
he's far ahead 40 70 right good nice nice I will get finned.
They probably have altar.
Yeah, try to get it quick.
Got it.
Nice.
I'm hitting you over.
I'm gonna lose his blocks real quick.
Uh, laser?
I'm good on that.
Alright.
I should fucking off AK it.
One's coming back.
I can kill them if you want.
He was like on the tracks here.
Oh, there's a scoping.
I need that.
They TP'd away.
Wait, there's a prowler.
They're resing.
Run up.
Yeah, I'm done.
We'll put a TP in here real quick.
I have EMP.
Yeah, put TP down.
Let's just start walking up.
It should be on, they're gonna be on blue actually.
Yeah, they're up here.
You can queue on them and I can EMP.
Yeah, I'm done.
They're trying to shoot that drone out.
I'm close.
They're playing Syracusek.
Just follow him directly?
Yeah, I got shot at.
I'm gonna shot at him.
You're safe on me.
Save on me.
Just probably just come back.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You can take the TP if you need.
Yeah, I'm gonna take it.
Yeah, just taking it behind us.
Yeah.
I got needed, but...
Hitman's game behind us all.
Just now.
It's gonna be close.
We can go into the diner.
Just cross the street.
Yeah, it's a crypto team.
I have an evac as well now.
Alright.
3x here if you need it.
One of you need that.
I'm gonna try to hit the UAV and then just see what's up.
Done.
Probably just gonna go grab this info and get the no name as
well.
Is Team Ranking Tunnel?
You guys can start moving over into the no name right now.
I don't know what's going on in no name I mean overlook is
just like gonna be full for a hmm this he might run straight
into us so you maybe kill this guy on the Eva okay I'm
looking for it run right I'm right behind guys come one is
up the hill two up the hill I might be the other that could
be ratting maybe oh they probably just got a crawler
actually off that real quick yeah you should if you need a
better gun grab enhance
you have tp back up five percent i need another i just need
to look for some heavy real quick we should get up the hill
and go put tp in the tunnel and then get ring three in the
back of they have a gold they grab the gold bow I'm dropping
this laser this thing's gonna grief me I feel like how to
gear does he I'm gonna put on this right side over here I
think yeah I'm getting on drone I'm just gonna see if
they're in the back we have one on stand okay one is over
here he sees my drone
Yeah, they're playing on the back lake on the jungle gym, so
the donut.
Team evacking into no name.
I just want to keep tabs on these guys.
They look like they want to come up our way, but they just
grabbed the eva, so they might not.
Might have just been flying for the eva.
Yeah, I see him.
They're loot sticking.
Yeah, they're moving north.
Yeah, they're crossing.
I want to see if...
should get out of our way over the left side after they hit
console they have blue on us yeah no name team is fully off
all right they're gonna shot up by hell right now they might
go back none them these guys are super split if you guys
want to watch start walking up together you can you can get
console and just force this guy off it's one guy at the back
here right now teammates are over in my yellow paint
teammates are all these days all yeah yeah if he stays all
EMP him and you guys can just kill him.
Can you light for him?
He's on jungle gym right now.
He's a Cossack.
I have to shoot his burrow.
Oh, hey, no, then.
Yeah, they're going to back him up.
Moving towards the two, sorry.
You can probably grab a console.
Yep.
I'm going to get 80% off.
Oh, there's another barrel.
Never mind.
They can see you from here.
Don't.
Yeah.
I won't do it.
I can take the jump with him and shoot him off.
Alright, let me know what to do.
Just move my body over.
If they stay there, we'll fight them.
I can do it.
Come.
I don't think you're going to be able to.
We're going to have to fight them.
You just have nades?
Yeah, I have one grenade and two grenades.
I have one grenade.
We're going to have to vernade them off this way.
There's two squads.
Okay, bye.
I'm going to hit you, AV, and just see what...
Yeah, they're close.
They have a tier team too.
It's your crypto probably.
They're just sitting on the roof still.
I see them.
Two teams.
Wait, they're teammates in garage.
It's just one guy here.
No, it's two guys.
Two guys.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's two guys.
I just set up to like queue through towards them.
I'm gonna EMP.
I'm just over.
A serious game.
Just wait.
Let's wait.
I'm moving forward off this.
I'm trying.
He's jumping off.
Getting fucked in the back.
He's on your right on the outside.
He went in, went in.
They fucked off.
They went into the garage.
Can you jump console now?
Yeah, I'm gonna grab it.
I'm gonna grab it.
There's three teams nearby now.
Team progress.
I'm doing now.
I'm trying to check our background.
Our back looks fine.
Got it.
We're probably just going to move here.
Yeah, move.
Let's move to my thing.
Come on.
You want to go from the left?
Yeah.
I can just put a TV if anything as well.
I'll put a TV.
You guys need shields or anything?
I think he needs shields or anything.
Oh.
I'm going to die here.
Hold on.
shoot the charging i only have somalia literally one i have
phoenix hit if anyone needs it here i can drop you two bats
i'll take the grenade go someone just hit uav in no name
yeah yeah three squads here three squads one team under
tunnel yeah these guys are over here we're just playing into
the left space in the platform i'm gonna keep my body here
we enter here Yeah, we're in there now.
You can play forward onto the platform.
Yeah, I'm gonna queue through it.
Might just want to play low key.
Don't shoot these guys at all.
They look like they're posturing to fight the team on the
respawn building.
Yeah, they're posturing for it right now.
They're walking up.
You can take their roof, Funk.
You go.
I'm going now.
Yeah, both of you, start walking forward.
Start walking forward.
Both of you.
Take their roof.
You can break their TP in their building.
Tears can be from underground.
Oh, OK.
Cut.
Gerry?
Did I go?
Yeah, they're all in the courtyard here.
Yeah, I'm going to go.
I have two shots on the Cossack.
Cossack one.
Dead.
We can take the voting.
They're gonna TP back on me.
Yeah, yeah.
You can try to get the thirst.
They're TPing back.
Get the thirst.
Get the third one.
I'm off my drone.
I'm coming back here, guys.
Got the third?
I'm not.
I'm getting all the stuff for y'all.
I'm just gonna kill .
No, they're not.
They're not.
Drop out what they saw in the building.
There's a guy in the open here on my ping.
There's a really good spot now.
Can you peek our roof and get a free kill on this guy here?
Yeah, I'm peeking it.
I meant kit.
I thought you were shooting the other bin.
I see him.
That's the tunnel team.
You see bin.
Yeah, tunnel team.
They might fight on the right here.
I might have a free kill in a second.
One on my body.
Not in the car.
Got in the car.
I think it's a duo on a solo.
Play on farm's head.
Okay, okay.
Just put it right away.
Hold his hand.
Oh, okay, okay, okay, I'm coming right here.
Okay.
I'm queuing it.
Yeah, they're trying to box ours right now, but they're just
sticking your eyes.
Giving you scans.
I'm looking, I'm looking.
It's two.
Come on.
Nice, one on the balcony.
I'm gonna EMP when this guy lands so you can look for this
guy.
He's over here, he's over.
I got him, I got him, I got him.
Landing on your head, Doki.
Landing on your head.
He's on scans.
Okay.
Cracked him.
One.
I'm watching my body now.
Okay.
Nice.
on the front.
Go back, go back, go back.
Yeah, one guy walking up to our building.
One guy, one guy.
I'm watching him.
He's on scan.
I'm here.
A bad one quick.
He's going to run back.
A teammate in the open here.
He's on the blue bin too.
I see him, I see him.
He was right here, here.
It's just him.
The teammate's on crafter.
We're gonna go back down.
Can we take that building back up?
And I can throw the TP in there.
Uh, you can go.
I think we want to stay here on the edge.
Just go, you can go grab loot.
There's one guy here.
All right, I'm putting that TP here.
Cause that building's going to get stuck!
sandwich later.
Oh, I agree.
Doki, play our route.
They needed that area.
Go out the back.
I'm playing low end.
And then climb onto the blue bin.
This blue bin.
They're peeking from here.
One just died on this team, I think.
I'm leaving real quick.
Yeah, they're recalling who died here.
Uh, tunnel team?
I know there's a guy up here, but I don't know if you move.
Yeah, they went away.
They went away.
You're good.
Is there heavy ammo on those things?
Uh, I think we have a hold.
I think we have a hold.
or a power pile on.
Double ultimate HP or sooner.
Yeah, they have the O-Star on me.
Ducky, if you need, I can give you your ammo.
No, I'm good right now, I'm good right now.
I have 200.
Look at zone.
Yeah.
I'm trying to like find something that's in.
There's nothing.
We're gonna probably have to hold it back.
Yeah, I have an e-bag.
we're probably we're probably gonna have to just pop both
our evacs and just like fly in on something this team down
here has all siren stuff yeah this fucking building is gone
yep um i think i'm gonna walk up a van look there's a
catwalk going on yeah yeah look down on this funk they're
catwalking on the rv and they're fighting we can we can play
down on that three play down we can we can wipe the team on
the tracks i think i think they left this they left this car
they left this car i'll we can take it yeah yeah take the
cart take the right one take the right one it's better i
think 100 and all turn open they're imping me i think i'm
good i'm not in one's on the right card they're exploding
cards i might be dead i can't do it i have a respawn peeking
i don't think you're res me i have to call out of this blue
crate ducky i'm going to emp the cart on the right yeah yeah
try to rest him i'm going to I'm gonna need like I'm gonna
need like I'm gonna bring my life.
I'm gonna get on me maybe I'm gonna try to get him up I'm
mutel dumping them.
I'm doing it.
I stuck one.
I'm gonna slide forward and just play play big on this.
Oh I got him I got him.
Can you slide away I'm ducking?
Yeah.
I shoot on two I shoot on them I shoot on the bad.
You guys need to fight.
Alter one Alter one.
Yeah just play the fight.
Play the fight.
I'm gonna shot from the side.
Slide forward.
Altar's the leg one.
Crap's up.
I got hit I got hit I'm using my shield oh no no nice nice
nice bump in plane rise I'm playing trip take fine trip take
five oh no no no no no no
oh it's just you fine oh good game good game good game yeah
that's what just I'm just so I'm like so many things going
on yeah there's a lot they have added way too much it's okay
i mean a plan alter crypto soon yep one what two kills by
the way they have been afk on all oh you guys got kill
points right you got people like that your squad even an afk
back of the map while we're handling business and over with
hey kill points though kill there's no way in bottom five of
kill points yeah hey all good we got we all have more kills
than phony guys we're all guys we're all wait was that phony
scene we all got more kills than phony that's all that
matters it's crazy oh they're just hanging out in that must
be nice having a home i'm so confused that left car is free
now i think that team just decided to like feed face for the
right car yeah they tp back yeah yeah 100 because they
fought they tried to fight the team in the rv wait bony's
team died first i didn't even realize whose team died first
bony's team they died what do you mean they died first Bruce
in the lobby No, I was in the lobby They were the first team
eliminated Oh my god Oh, this is even This isn't even funny
scene I'm trolling Yeah, I was gonna Yeah Why did I think
this was funny scene?
Yo, no, I'm actually fried Wait, I'm actually just flaming
Fony for no reason I'm just flaming bronzy this whole time
It's less than 100 things And I was just like Clocking it
was Fony Yeah, I just thought you were just like Whoa, why
are you flaming Fony's not even here Yeah, it's like he was
eliminated first though and he was technically you're
technically right.
Yeah, you were technically right.
Yeah.
Yeah, we're still good on that.
They had double o-star runaway and we just double l-star.
Yeah, they kept on getting the ultra l star.
I should have just popped my pylon up there.
That was my bad for dying open.
I should have just never shot.
I just got instantly.
I should have popped the pylon too, but I was just like 800
gunshots in my head.
I felt like I was at Vietnam.
Did you say it felt like I was in Vietnam?
I was in the front lines there.
I don't know.
That was a beautiful res.
That was a beautiful res for me.
In the EMP it was good.
The EMP actually saved me out what I got there, Sid.
Yeah, they were trying to wide swing out the cart.
For example, I was starting with my knockdown.
They were blowing it up.
like 800 to 200 in a second yeah i was just like i see you
and then you disappeared in my eyes yeah that's like
vaporized yeah it was like saving private puff
don't guys don't worry it's warm up guys it's warm up after
that after this i'm so locked in I'll be so locked in after
this Do not worry It's all warm up Yeah first game is always
warm up I needed my brain to catch up You know My brain is
still in the Bahamas I never left I never left the Bahamas
Oh
Oh shit, the team that killed, technically we could, we're
like second place because the team that killed us got first.
I don't think that's the other place.
We died to the winning squad.
True, true, we were in the game winning spot.
Yeah, yeah.
There's an 11 pointer.
A little 11 pointer, that's good.
A little 11 point, that's good.
You got more points than everyone above us basically
besides.
Second and first, yeah.
Yeah.
Well, if those guys don't have devil, I'll start, I don't
even think they knock one of us, so.
Probably, yeah.
It was Apex of Warlords.
Apex Warlords?
Who is that?
Yeah, see?
It was Blast.
Oh, look at number 15.
You were right.
You were right, Fah.
What?
Look at match something.
Look at match number...
Were they duo?
Oh, no, they weren't.
Foney just...
Wait.
wait they did get zero they did get they did get zero yeah
they got zero zero they got they got one point actually
because it's top 15 everyone gets oh true true it's actually
funny oh man goop again got 13th place they were the ones
with that logo all
right apparently it's like new lobby every game new lobby
every game yeah new code from what they said he's blast said
whoever stuck me suck it you didn't want a lot where he
threw that shit across the bed oh my god it was like an 80
meter stick that's actually fucking insane
what's the ban you know what's bad mac i gave you honorary
or co-captain you can be co-captain
everyone ain't seen comp Altar is gone, so probably not.
We can play...
Depends where we're at, I guess, so I don't know what we're
playing.
Ooh, Noddy and them aren't calling yet.
Phony's not calling.
Yeah, but that's three more games.
There's three more games, though.
Let's just act like they're going to get zero every game.
They didn't make it.
Wait, we have to be safe before I say anything.
yeah i'm gonna say we're not safe yet bro no we're safe
we're safe i'll we're all locked we're all locked we're so
locked i'm so locked we're all locked we're safe bro yeah
team 14 gets like group two gets like 14 teams what the only
we were on group two i wonder is group two harder or easier
i haven't looked at it but this hobby is pretty easy let me
see group two group two beers and team years and tears wait
how do you see group two i don't see it i'll link it put in
our group chat go the team 11 chat yes yes yep thank you
beers and tears
uh depending on poi we might just play like some some axle
crypto well if we get like an edge Like, I'll just play
crypto again, put Funk on Axel.
And then Mox it again.
I can play whatever I want.
Oh, don't give...
Yeah, you ever played Fuse?
I feel like you on Fuse would be kind of funny.
Me on Fuse.
I think I'm going to hurt myself.
Not going to lie.
I think I think I'm a...
You take the knuckle jumper.
I'll be a detriment to the team.
You have Fuse unlocked.
You just rocket jump up the air and fucking dunk your fuse
all on people's heads i'm just the wild card if it hits it
hits right guys i'll i'll tell let you know right now let me
see the hours i have on feed it changed fees completely no
it doesn't even matter the hours i have 955 apex damage on
fees that sort of explains how much i played it might have
been like a one or two game thing it's okay if he's all you
do is pick the blue perk the blue okay is it the left one
out or is it the right one it might be the rocket jumper or
the fire yeah the rocket jumper yeah might be the right one
the left one which one i think it's the left one i think
it's the right one it's the one that's not called
pyrotechnics pyrotechnics is the one with fire the other one
i'm pretty sure it's called jump here okay oh shit basically
just throw the thing you throw the cue at your feet and then
you just jump okay yeah yeah you can like you like slide
jump and then fucking knuckle jump your feet and you'll go
flying all right we're gonna test that out in game I guess
if we get a good POI for it yeah dude it's awesome I feel
like we're being in the air and then it's gonna be duck hunt
for me like they're just I mean I'm not gonna lie that could
happen no no no you be fine you can jump short you can jump
short all right we're gonna learn it while we're looting in
the po i guess you'll be able to practice it while you can't
practice until we have blue that's oh true i'm gonna do it
yeah unfortunately there's so there's so many rules i
thought it was a simple thing guys but there's like extra
criteria it's actually not that simple at first okay all
right there's like asterisks asterisks asterisks what do you
it's gonna take me he doesn't know move well you play marvel
you play marvel yeah okay okay yeah same thing obviously
very similar like it we're doing it live i'm like you guys a
little guinea pig right now what can we make or you do while
we play it's like entertain me like entertain me plat player
you're not even a plat though you hit press what do you know
no no no no no i'm the plat player here i'm the plat player
in the rules i'm the plat player definitely definitely a
plat player
my most my most no i was a during when i did the predgrind i
played pathfinder and watson That's why they have my Watson
skin.
That's my actual skin.
That's cool.
All right, where is...
Wait, why is alternate band?
They've messed up the band.
They're going to restart, I think.
Maybe they just be like...
Wait, where's City Hall?
Maybe it's more so it's like what's called, like, in-house
rules where we hope you don't pick it.
Yeah, I mean, someone's definitely clicking that.
They're just like...
honor system you know it's like i hope none of you guys pick
her it's a triple plat yeah yeah i'm the flat i'm the flat
and i'm here to represent you guys out there you're actually
about to get more kills in this next match than you have on
fees this is gonna be this is gonna be a movie let's do it
so the fusel to it works you can shoot it through walls okay
you mean at a wall it'll be a different color all right amen
now all right we got this you don't really want to you you
usually don't want to do that though oh okay you just want
to free fire because the the impact of it actually hitting
the floor does a fuckload of damage so you want to just
direct shot people with it gotcha yeah you could do like
some crazy stuff when i make it like fly up in the air at
your queue and then do a crazy fusel i don't think that's
what we're seeing today like no we'll see it you're about to
like i was like i'm baiting them i'm pretending to run away
and then i tap straight back and be like hey here's the bomb
no i gotta see this you gotta see me i like yeah i'm gonna
bring up the all and just like die with it oh that's gonna
be what happening in my head you know my imagination no when
you get it down just wait till you you're gonna learn it
you're gonna learn i'm gonna learn right yeah it's not it's
not that if it's it's literally just like this is a small
timing thing with the uh with the fuse key for jumping like
you'll feel it out really yeah yeah yeah after like the
first five fuse ults i do in this game right i'm gonna live
that long to see it yeah yes we're in end game yeah dude
when we're in end game trust me you're gonna be you're gonna
be having the time of your life on fuse because there's a
there's a perk there's a perk on fuse it so your old
cooldown gets like refreshed when you do explosive damage so
you just keep fucking old thing off cooldown constantly and
your old doing damage like gives you basically your old back
as well so okay just hit a fat you can just double old
somebody oh i could just like just start ripping it
basically yeah you don't even need to shoot your gun you're
that's great i hope that happens i like how you're i like
how you're saying all these things and then it's not like i
hope i get to see it like settlement oh my we just gotta be
the worst comp out of settlement you know how to run a
stadium you take their loot bro this is bad it'll be fine we
have heavy it sounds way too good to make it happen in the
game that's so true yes this will be fine do i am i still on
fuse after all yeah you are i don't know it's i did very
hopeful but you were like settlement no this is literally
one of the worst people eyes for this but it's gonna work
we're gonna make it work mac you remember what happened you
remember when we got eliminated by one point that won't
happen we're gonna kill the whole server i was actually
trying to grieve us he's actually yeah he's actually trying
to grieve us he wants to i don't think there's anybody
humbert i don't think there's nobody humbert there's no one
humbert yeah just So like if they fly here, then like it's
just hands I think one guys I can't tell actually It might
just be hands though like off rip All right I'm down for
hands off rip Fuck I need to look at my abilities guys Give
me a sec Check the right one I think it's the right one on
the blue one And that's the knuckle jumper It's literally
called knuckle jumper Yeah yeah it should be right left All
right Oh I have a red We're gonna kill this old dad too.
Okay.
I have one P20 at the moment.
There's a hemlock here.
There's a hemlock here next to the Spitfire.
I have double P20s.
I don't know if I want these though.
I'm Nemicar.
Well, can you get a prowler?
We have a heavy crafter.
I have a car now.
Is Scout good or no?
Yeah, it's not bad.
best they are but oh it hemlock still still the best yeah
well flounder mk is pretty good but controller talking i
almost killed the seer in old town i'm waiting for this
heavy craft there real quick oh it's gonna spawn in a second
all right i'm juiced i'm just watching this old town too see
i'm gonna grab the hemlock then one's like out right like
over here grab this maybe 240 yeah whatever yeah I can't
they're going around yeah I see them all right let's just go
north we're not gonna kill them crypto it's here they're on
a hard fighting comp yeah just go north we'll fuck off if
they're playing
crypto it's a team with another good like actual good player
on it all right wait they might fight on that eva yeah they
probably will i'll drown this evo for us and you guys can
start moving over towards that all right yeah i'm gonna go
just stay glued to funk dokey at all times all right i'll i
don't know if that's that might not be a great calm because
uh sometimes i do some stupid on axel well her life is in
your hands yeah my life is in your hands if you want me to
do the jumper.
All right, let's test this out.
How do I do this?
I don't see them here.
Don't do it over here.
Okay, so Q.
So what you want to do, Doki, is Q slightly in front of you,
then slide jump.
Okay.
Come over here.
You have to do it.
There you go.
Yeah.
All right.
I hurt myself.
Do a little earlier.
You want to do it before it wards up.
Oh, okay.
Do it before I hurt.
You know, that would have been a good comm before I did it.
So if you jump while you're... If you jump while you're on
it, then it will detonate early.
Oh, I see.
I see.
out your feet like this and then run in front of it a little
bit can i do it here or do it do i where do i jump towards
go over just throw it in front of you and then oh now you
get it back faster every like you get it back so fast when
you do that yeah it's only like a three second cooldown
we're gonna all right this is actually like duck hunt yeah
yeah you can literally do that the whole time we're rotating
around just like keep getting comfortable with it because
the cooldown is super short oh i missed the queue I want to
grab this UAV.
I swear to God, if I'm practicing this and I get shot down,
I swear to fucking God, guys.
You won't.
You'll be all right.
Look, you're moving.
Oh my God, I'm just moving right now.
Yeah, you actually are.
You can just loot up through here if you guys need anything.
Pretty good.
I just need, like, fast.
Oh, it's a good idea.
Team Stadium still.
We can go fight these guys.
They're going to go for the...
the there's an evo in the choke let's go fight these guys
all right you have it you have mp yeah i have emp we should
have fusel they're gonna come through and then we just
fucking blow them up all right i'm gonna miss my fusel but
i'm just glued on funk watch me miss this all guys it's
gonna be crazy on the thing just hit blue one's called blow
me blow me up just axelq out them they're up here they're
all over 100 on one axelq up on them i'm gonna pull it up no
no No, don't.
Use your own.
Pop your own.
I missed.
I'm so.
You're good.
They put it away.
It's a ray-cluster queue.
I did.
I'm practicing.
Right on my ping.
You have drone still?
And here.
No, I used that.
I didn't think they're going to put it away.
I have a thermite.
You need it here.
I'm throwing it to you.
I have a thermite.
Try to hit those here.
You can keep it.
They're into the left.
I think that did look cool with them.
They are scared.
Yeah, they are scared.
I mean they saw me do that tick if you guys can go meet them
at that Yeah, I'm going behind us behind us full team
careful.
Oh shit.
All right leave go.
I might be a duo That's a full team.
Yeah, I'm coming for them.
They're running back out back out steer one steer one I'm
leaving Yeah, we're just gonna go and let them fuck off this
way.
There's too many people around here now.
Oh my god the portal I almost landed to the portal 3k pizza
I did not see that I slid into your thing and I fucking
almost flattened into the portal I almost did that too I
have zero bats if you guys have any I have zero this is like
rough I have two I can give you guys bats I can give one
person a bat I just give it the funk we'll just keep moving
around I have to get on low bay here this new loop yeah
we'll just scrap loot as we go this is like all leading
through that
Wait, someone died already.
That Northroth's pretty good.
I'm gonna look to hit the CIV.
There's a team here.
They're TPing away.
It looks like they're fighting or something.
I think one of them got knocked.
Yeah, he's TPing here.
Seer Wraith, him.
We're just gonna keep going around to the north edge of the
map.
We can get through all this.
Galarra's running back, Charlie.
If you do it while you slide jump, Doki, you can get like a
really good angle and basically launch yourself forward.
Oh, okay.
I'll try that.
That makes sense.
So you put it slightly in front of you and then slide jump
into it.
Like that?
Or could you go even further?
No, a little closer.
Closer to yourself.
Okay, okay, okay.
I could get like some air time.
You'll basically launch yourself horizontally.
Because you want to like be as close to the floor while
you're doing it.
Okay, okay.
Get some air time.
Want to keep wrapping, right?
Yeah, we'll just keep wrapping around.
Here we go.
Oh, I see.
I see.
I see my third eyes open.
Yeah, you can fucking fly on that character.
I get it now.
If you ever get big entry damage on someone, you rip that at
them and then fuse ult their face oh okay okay i get it i
just gotta hit the fuse ult now i just gotta figure out how
to do the fuse ult pull it pull it out if you have it yeah
just shoot it wherever like your the circle is you can look
through look through the wall real quick and aim it in you
can see the different color on yours oh i see yeah if you
aim it in if you aim it aim down sight it'll breach the wall
oh oh you don't want to do that unless it's like a new
castle team or like they're stuck in a corner there's a team
here generally you be purple here now they're gonna see us
soon probably he's like four off see your cat rath rath
knows i'm aiming at their yeah they see us it's in the build
ducky try to try to get damage on these guys get your purple
armor ducky i got purple nice and then take the one that uh
gives you i think it's the left one explosive damage
explosive damage explosive damage gives you out back okay
there's a team in here too Okay, so I have one shield cell
left.
One shield cell.
Yep.
I can give you shields.
Let's just go back into, let's go back into Galleria and
just loot then if she's off there.
There's three cells.
I don't have any dots.
I have one bat, nine cells.
I did not see...
No, it's fine, it's fine.
I got some.
We're just gonna play for the bin reset in Galleria.
I am.
Come on.
I'm rich in in small meds for health.
I just said you had one.
Oh, I was going to say you just had one.
In HP.
I'm going to hit this UAV.
On my hemlocks max.
It's beautiful UAV.
I mean, we just hold our go play up in here.
Yeah, we'll just make sure that no one comes from eBank.
Where?
And then...
On this choker.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You can craft a buy here.
Make sure no one comes for me, bank.
And then I'll loot around on the bins and stuff for you.
You can craft a buy here, Doug, if you want real quick.
Yeah, I'm gonna craft it.
And then I'll go to the hut.
Do you have a lot of nades, Jack?
Um, no, I just have a thermite.
Here.
They have Krabber, okay?
Krabber on one of these buildings.
Yeah, here.
I can take these nades.
All right.
Where are you?
Blue armor.
All right.
check it rings close and closing in 45 it's moving time god
i feel so poor yeah i'm 2a1 phoenix i feel so modern apex
man i've never felt this way before it's been like 10 years
since i felt this poor in apex my little itty bitty white
backpack I don't know which guy is Craver.
Your cue will still do damage to people by the way.
Okay I'm gonna cue them then.
Yeah.
Yeah you just have a longer cooldown when you actually use
it on someone.
Oh I hit something.
Good.
Opponent hits something.
They're shooting at me.
I'm healing my shields.
There's a team in parking roads.
There's two teams over here and then one team in five stack.
When zone closes in more, like people are gonna fight on
this side, I think.
We might be able to work something.
If not, and there's just a team playing these little builds,
we can just blow them the fuck up with Utah and just force a
spot if we have to.
Yeah I'm done.
Really far zone.
Wow.
Do we have Evacs?
Can you hit this on the corner of the boat?
on the corner over here yeah yeah i can we have evacs we
have two i'm guessing the other side of the zone might be
free can you see my end my range no i need to move my body
forward i'm gonna like look for you a little bit should be
all right i'm probably fighting on this side this side of
energy bank yeah they are oh they got that creeper shot in
that whole side's free we're gonna come to me right now all
right let's hope by last Double?
Call both E-backs.
Yeah, I'm dropping mine over there.
We're going to fly just into the, there's like an alley here
we can fly.
All right, I hope I make it.
I think we can make it.
Yeah, we definitely do.
We make it.
I can queue you if you need Doki.
Whoa, I'm landing.
We're good in this alley.
I'm getting on drone.
I make it.
Do you queue in case?
The team's trying to angle us.
Let's play this side of the alley and we should be okay for
now.
Okay, this team will shop here.
You play beyond the dumpster for now.
Start, like, fused skewing this team.
Show them that we're like a dangerous comp a little bit.
They're like playing out a lot.
Just shoot fused skews at these guys.
They have conduit.
I hit him.
Oh, that's fucking, that's my fucking roommate.
Go over there right now and unplug his PC.
I know who that is.
that's jelly go there right now to plug his pc he won't know
third party his ass
we should be okay i'm making sure that we don't get robbed
from our south right now we're probably gonna kill them on
next uh next zone if they're still in and we're not all
right
guys he can't turn up his wi-fi they're in the same house
they have purple they might fight on our back they're gonna
fight here Yeah I got a dokey and look at it Sort of harass
them to like not do anything you can like play out here, I
think Yeah, you can you can Want me to be with you or?
We I mean we need to kill these guys on yellow bang Like you
guys stack up and get to get control of this space funk like
axel cube from where I am and get control of this space I'll
EMP and you guys can take space on them I'm queuing from
here.
You can double jump off of it.
All right.
I'm burning it in.
Oh, oh, he broke it.
He broke it.
They broke the queue.
Let's play the space normally for now.
I've got my drone here.
I got Chris again.
Yeah, I'm Sean.
You're good.
Doki, you can cross to him with your queue maybe.
No, they broke my drone.
All right.
I get ducked on it.
Conner, one, conner one.
No, no, no, no, no.
Nice.
Cross, Doki, cross.
Cue over to him.
I fucked it up.
Don't!
Get over there!
Oh my god!
I crossed!
Fusal with them!
That's not their EMP.
Just apply pressure, Doki.
I'm racing.
They died.
It's an EMP now.
You need EMP out?
Okay.
Unscan.
You have Fusal?
Fusal through the wall!
I already did it.
You told me to do it.
Let me go.
I'm gonna peek around.
They're pushing.
Path one!
Nice!
One more here!
Swing it!
Nice!
Res, res, res, res, res, res, res, res, quick!
Res, res, res, res, res, res, res, res, res, res.
Drop armor, swap.
Doki, take the swap.
I dropped armor for both.
All right.
Look right, look right.
I need a Medi.
Do you have a Medi?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, do I drop it on four.
Dropping two on the floor.
We have to play the left side.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Over here.
We have a rock.
Okay.
Hey, guys.
It's working.
We have all the cells.
I don't know.
No, no, no.
We're going in left space.
Oh, we're going.
Wait.
I think we have all left.
Doki, play out here.
Doki, play out here with me a little bit.
Oh, you?
Okay.
Two cryptos.
You can peek down on this.
You can peek down on this with your stuff.
You just give this.
Okay.
I'm giving you scans.
There you go.
Pull you the shotgun.
Okay, guys.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Ray, tell me, on the other left side here.
I'm holding it.
It's fun.
Doki, you can...
You might...
Never mind.
Don't play up on that.
Building will fuck us up.
Do I...
Do you want me to go back?
Let's go back towards Funk.
Okay.
Let's cross back.
I think they're fighting on here.
I'm going to try to beat this.
Okay.
Just don't kill yourself.
I'm getting on drone for you.
Yeah, I'm good.
I'm good.
We just need to make sure that we control the street and we
win the game.
Am game.
I'm getting out of it.
I have a hundred heavy for double by the way.
I can give.
I have a shitload.
Yeah.
They're pushing in this building.
Here, everyone.
Come in.
I just want to hold this left face and then we won the game.
One team multi-low ground resetting right now and then one
team in the building.
Okay, I'm going to hold our left wrap then and I'll queue
back up on you.
Hello.
Ducky, you can queue this door off, but you can just keep
bullying that team inside.
Alright.
They're playing the bottom floor right now, one guy at
least.
crypto team crypto team this is a cat team dokey can you
play play over here by me and just like bully this staircase
we want to force them to go left like make sure like you can
play the van and just like if you see them go here then you
just cue it let me drop I'm gonna drop down a bit yeah just
be careful make sure you can get back they're gonna go your
side dokey they're gonna go your side okay just need to
force the building team Yeah, they're gonna slide out.
Lean towards Funk now.
Can we break their drone?
Okay, cross back towards Funk.
Come on, bro.
I broke down.
I broke down from building to my thing.
Got it.
Team Thunder is on crypto 100%.
Gale them all.
They're gonna slide.
Their crypto wraith on low ground.
They're gonna portal out of low ground.
I'm just hard holding these guys.
They're gonna need an MP.
The wraith is TPing now.
They're needing them.
Raith is here, Raith is here, portal's here.
Really good mid, really good mid.
They cabled off their side of zone.
Yeah, I'm...
One team's playing height, one team's playing on the low.
They're trying to peek down on them.
Doki, Doki, Fuse, Fuse ult this.
Fuse ult this.
All right.
Fuse ult.
I Fuse ult, I Fuse ult.
Duse ult.
Duse, Duse, Duse, Duse, on my ping.
Oh, oh, I hate all that.
Pique, peak, peak, peak, peak, guys.
I mean ping, peak.
So much damage.
I got one, I got one, I got one.
Just get kills, get kills.
it's it's last team last team last guy last guy last guy
yeah look at that fuse let's go i'm in the zone yeah we did
it who needs meta who needs meta guys do you see hella
damage numbers when you That was crazy.
I saw so many numbers on my screen.
I was like, whoa.
Yeah, that was crazy.
I didn't even need to shoot your gun.
Oh, my God.
There were so many numbers.
I didn't know how that, I never felt that way before.
Okay, that was an aura.
That was an aura jump, though.
And I just shot him in the, it's like a single.
Oh, that was funny.
I'm like, go ahead, fuck, okay.
It goes straight up.
i was trying to break this axle and i just couldn't break it
it was an aura it's like we're signaling them that we're
coming you know my p.m is so funny because i was looking
straight at you wouldn't you be like i was like watching to
see if you'd hit it i wonder if anyone else saw like if any
other teams saw them be like what the fuck are they doing
i need to go pee i'll be right back guys yeah i'll be right
back real quick
mute it yet but i'm having fun this team is so i always like
playing mac he's a chill guy he knows how to bring the vibes
duck bite zekra on your end many solid four alan thank you
mr richard thank you thank you i it's i hope you guys are
having fun watching too no i i it's been a fun fun game so
far you know i'm just fucking yeah
good content we clip farming like a real content creator
yeah it's uh i was like we're running it back mac like i
said he left his old team just to be on my team i was just
like bro he's straight like i don't even know who i'm
playing i might as well join your team and i was just like
okay bro get mine in yeah he's a real real one yeah what a
bro okay let me
i was like who are you playing with it's like and i was like
i don't know who they are like i don't know either
all right up to fall a little bit more sound team so let me
know if it's better i didn't talk so anyway all right I'm
back.
Do we know what's banned now?
Oh, is no one else back?
It's just me?
Guys, you're not...
Oh, are you here?
Do you know what's...
Do you know what they're banning next?
Oh, Seer.
They're banning Seer.
That's all right.
None of us were playing Seer.
Same comp.
Let's go.
Because it worked so well, obviously.
we did win all right who's gonna get eliminated who's close
to getting eliminated
all right running back now that POV of yours I was too funny
yeah just like oh yeah did you send him the POV I'll be
going straight in the air hey you're doing better on hey you
did better to me on my i couldn't even cue the first time i
played that character what do you mean you said it took you
five minutes or some shit no i was doing the double jump
thing and i was just like not doing it in time like the name
oh it was a controller moment there's a controller moment
you had a better you had a way better first fuse game than
i've ever had yeah that's true that's true i won my first
fuse game that was beautiful look at that and now i'm gonna
win my second fuse game right guys i mean let's double that
damage number we can run it yeah we're running it back if
ain't broke why why fix it exactly let's see 100 when you're
right let's see oh we're gonna let it ride it's gonna be 50
or 100 now we're gonna of them are still not not calling
right now guys oh shit same for both phony and them got
fourth with zero kill oh bro bronzy's team is currently with
wow 32 points yeah they're trying to beat us we have to we
have to beat them you gotta level up but only we can have
two fuses on a team imagine two fuses flying through there
yeah flying through it double as fuselts double fusel did
you get your fusel fusal back in the end yeah yeah yeah
fusel to them no did you get it back though oh i don't know
i was not i was just i got distracted by all those numbers
on my screen i no yeah you get all the numbers popped up and
you went cross-eyed you're like yeah well
going up right now or what group 2 who's not having a fun
time in group 2 we're having a great time in group 1 yeah
we're having a great time a fucking blast yeah and they wish
they were us yeah literally Group 2 seems like easier points
are like people have less points in group 2 let me go see
yeah some teams have zero kills or yeah in group two there's
like four teams of zero three teams with zero kills
overall how did you aces zero and duke everyone came out of
retirement for this tournament yeah dude literally have
names i haven't seen in like two years or just on that's
what i'm saying the loophole of the loopholes it's actually
crazy i'm so surprised they got zero out of deadlock ranks
he's been grinding that 15k bro wait where do i live
deadlock now yeah so i transitioned to deadlock when he
stopped playing he went full-time deadlock configuration
still an early game so yeah anything can change
oh you just kind of loot whatever you see at this bro it's
not much yeah it's not much yeah i Pre-patches POI didn't
have much, and now, believe it or not, it still has...
At least we're not playing on King's Canyon.
I don't want to know what that was like.
I don't want to relive that time.
King's Canyon?
Oh, no.
Yeah, King's Canyon?
I remember leaving Cage one game with a P20, and I think...
It was like P20 T-take, and I had like 20 bullets in my
T-take.
That is insane.
There's a...
here if you're broke i have a triple take r9 if you guys are
ready to go i have a flatline car i can give you guys one of
my guns you need it that's okay i got good guns i'm chilling
flatline car there's stuff up here ducky i'm gonna loot
these pills and then i'm coming those spiders there's a
longbow there if you want that ducky longbows are pretty
good and a mag.
Oh, no, I don't want to miss on stream.
You go here, Rob.
I'm not giving them that satisfaction.
The knuckle jumps are enough.
It's enough content for them.
Yeah, that's enough content.
They don't need more.
They don't need me whiffing longbow shots six times in a
row.
Maybe even seven.
Just come up here.
I'm heading over here.
Oh, shit.
It's time.
Whoa!
See, that was a good one.
Yeah, that was a good one.
You like that?
I'm not going to be able to do that when we're fighting,
though.
Oh, I actually don't need all these shields if you want
them.
Um...
I don't want to go to barometer.
All right.
We're going to hit up Barrow.
Hit this UAV.
Go.
Oh.
We got this evo.
Hey, guys.
I'm right here.
I don't know if you got a CSI.
Oh, there's a team nearby, apparently.
Uh, what type of team you need?
Yeah, one.
I have a 1x if you want it.
All in the north.
No, I need like a 3x or something.
I can give you the 3x.
I keep yours.
Keep yours.
You can be shooting your gun more than me.
I'm in drone.
All right.
I'm on iPad duty.
Oh, I'll just grab P20 there.
I'm fucking off.
Got it.
them.
I feel more comfortable with R&I, but you guys said it's ass
now, which makes me so bad.
It's literally you miss like two bullets and like you just
miss out on a kill.
That makes me so sad.
We have to go like 20 for 20 with that gun now.
You're serious?
Yeah, it's pretty bad.
Shooting by Sino, they might just be doing their spiders,
huh?
Something they're just doing spiders.
oh apex warlords dead oh shiv i think they might come out of
zone on our left here while we're going to the sea there's
an extra battle in this boat i have a i have bottomless so i
don't need it come i'm freaking rich right now i have a
white backpack but i'm freaking rich white backpack there's
a guy on the beach here they're just like looking at us
they're trying out i see him yeah there's a guy coming from
the left too the scene outside i'm going into the we should
we should just back up and go east just back in the water in
front of me two teams i'm gonna kill the crypto okay kill
the crypto nice get the kill if you can they're like in a
really bad spot bro are they are they punished right here
yes free kills okay right one ducky look ducky swing out
right with me come around they're all dead last team last
team over here i'm I'm done.
Where are they getting shot at, but?
He's six.
140.
We're shooting him, man.
One HP Axel.
On the blue bin.
I'm nading it.
Might be really good nades.
Yucky, take space.
Forward here with me.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm doing him right behind me.
They're running back.
100 on Conduit.
They're running up the hill now.
That's my fucking roommate.
Why are you on Conduit, bro?
I think you're going with that shit.
Yeah, actually feel bad because I looked at the ranks and I
killed the plow on Axel.
He's not actually flat.
Don't feel bad.
They're not actual flat.
Remember, they're just like me.
Wait, who's the conduit?
That's my roommate.
Oh, so he's not an actual.
It's not white jelly, but it's jelly.
It's white jelly.
Why jelly is their pro player.
My roommates are.
They're flat player.
Yeah.
Is your roommate the what's his name?
Is no play on console, right?
No, it's not on console.
I thought you had a roommate that I played on console
before.
That was fucking well.
different than that okay yeah okay i don't mix up yeah don't
feel bad he ain't real just like me i mean no don't feel bad
he ain't real but i'm real he doesn't play a lot of apex
when he's been masters so i'm just so it doesn't make a
difference really because masters and flat is just playtime
at this point yeah yeah season 12 buddy yeah oh season 12
just like literally four years ago there's a tautical here
if you need it i'm grabbing this pro actually i'm good on
laser fuck that yeah i'm gonna run it so hard for now oh you
want 3x i i dropped the 3x i grabbed i dropped the 3x you
want it yeah yeah i'll take it i have a two by four if you
want that no i got the 2x replicator incoming how good is
that okay let's uh let's go grab the cvo over
Watch this.
There was a...
3x as well.
3x, yeah.
I can't carry it, actually.
Maybe tap drone in case they're riding us?
Yeah, we're good.
I saw them on UAV.
They were going wide around Cascade.
Yeah, I didn't see it.
I'm not gonna lie.
I was not paying attention.
We're just gonna take a ride out here after I grab you the
drone.
And then just pass down the river.
Come.
Yeah.
there are no squads in the airs the rings far and she closes
into me i haven't even looked at zone once this game it's a
launch bed me too i'm just i'm just following our crypto you
don't need to think about it yeah we don't need to think we
just shoot we just shoot and jump we could try to fight also
i'm just gonna cross the river yeah i have the double jump
queue we need that
i just need a heavy magazine phone blue heavy mag no no keep
it i don't i don't want to take attachments from you no no
no no no no no you're the controller player no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no i'll take that i'll take
that and then it's no no no we feed you the best loot you're
our entry fraggy you gotta entry i just feel so bad taking
anyone's attachments no don't feel bad i'm flat
I'm gonna grab that and then come up like go take the zip up
the swim catcher all right I'm a little late I'll join the
two teams and we'll hit this UAV and then we'll come down
and fight this team in the corner all right you see the two
teams behind us up casket yeah yeah they're playing casket
so that should be all right our timing shouldn't line up
with those all right got me an upgrade so we're in a queue
here
Platt lives matter.
Not in this tournament guys.
Oh, someone died.
Platt would not have fun in this tournament.
I'm having fun.
Yeah, I'm the happiest Platt player here.
The happiest one.
Oh, what the fuck?
They're triple ratting.
I'm just blew myself on my own.
Run, Doki, run, run, run.
That is cool.
Go into gas in the command center.
Oh my god.
Q away, Q away.
I'm queuing, I'm queuing.
They'll never catch you if you do it right.
Yeah, I did it right.
No, you're actually doing it right.
Yeah, you're good.
They'll never catch me.
I'm so where do I go after that?
Go to that.
You see that crafter at double O?
Yeah, we go down here.
You don't have heals to heal in zone.
I mean so.
No, I do not.
How many kills do you have?
Let's test it out.
You think they'll cat me?
You're going to go back out the way you came in.
You should be fine.
They're not chasing you.
Do you have med kits?
Yeah, I do, I do.
There could be a team in this gas over here.
Yeah, just go back down the hill.
All right.
You might be able to just box rise off.
I doubt they're tanking gas.
All right.
Let's hope so.
They might be able to.
desperate for this kp no no no they won't they won't they
won't be there all right watch them be three deep in alb's
dev box right now yeah
we die here i guess no no no we're good we're gonna get back
to no i don't liar you fucking liar you really did wrap the
box you guys i'm seeing three Wait, is this three Prad
banners?
What's going on here?
You liars!
That was Koza.
Koza went and ratted the box.
I knew it.
I wanted to do the long game.
They need that KP.
It's okay.
My 100% fuse run rate.
God.
It's 50 now.
It's okay.
You can turn it into 75.
There'll never be a hundred, but there'll never be a
hundred.
hundred it's not the same but you guys see a sick movement
though you guys see that yeah you're actually moving yeah
you guys saw that yeah i figured it out yeah it's like i
broke i figured out the algorithm
now we have to watch this
we have to watch this boring gameplay conduit come on The
one time Mac...
Wait, this might have been the conduit thing where she...
This might have been.
The one time Mac didn't scan.
The one time.
Yeah, the one time.
They didn't scan.
I think they came from Elrod late.
Yeah, nah, to be fair, that was crazy.
I thought that team was just gonna be playing down in that
spot the whole time and we just had to load them for free.
They don't even have a console character.
I don't even know what they came up there for.
Wait, which team is this?
another name it's luke and koza gc they have a twitch tv joe
woe and look at the bracket where which what what are
standing are they at wait this is the last place we died to
the we gave the last place team two kills guys we they're
not gonna be last anymore they're not being gonna be last
anymore not joe woe yeah the joe's zaza team
After this, we have one last game.
And then, I think we qualify, right?
There's no way we don't qualify with those points.
I'm going to lose.
Oh, they're dead.
Oh, they're not.
No, Koza's on the move.
They're dead now.
Oh, no, wait, Koza's, wait, no, Koza's brand new.
No, that's Zuni.
The Axel Zuni.
Oh, is that?
I thought that was the last one.
All right, they're dead.
Yeah, they killed Koza already.
Never mind.
Ginny is really good, too.
I don't know, you said never mind there.
But Koza's like a little movement freak, so you put him on a
character like Axel, and he's just waking up.
Oh, he's one of those people with the movement montages,
right?
No, yeah, he is, yeah.
There's a good chance that he clips us and uses it as, like,
an intro from oh yeah just clip me like you standing afk on
your box look at the sick kill i just got it here
all right let me do some while they while all of this is
happening let me do some work stuff real quick okay oh my
god it's only trim guys not these games are going a lot
faster than yesterday that's all i'll say
not meant not meaning to like not mean to punch down or
anything but these games are going a lot faster already yeah
it was way I did I talked I told her it was too slow yeah
make that faster I'm cooling down in between games yeah no
I've done best of one in other rivals tournaments and they
go they can go by super fast but like for a best of one that
should felt so slow like we'd be like RR like like you know
RR go in and then but oh my god also because we're doing
ignite bands too i feel like ignite bands are way too
complicated for for like a creator tournament i ammo no this
is definitely not my setup guys
whose team is this i don't even know i don't even know whose
team this is
oh god they're naning they're naning yeah that's true i
think they should have made it all maps honestly yeah it
sucks that people can't adapt or anything but there's eight
teams man
there's there's eight teams bro if it was like six teams or
maybe like five like four it's fine but eight is a lot on a
map yeah because i had my microphone like in my face so now
you guys can actually I didn't realize how bad it was until
now because I had the microphone like in my face so I
lowered the mic a little bit more yeah and it's a one-day
turn too yeah so I lowered the microphone so you guys can um
it's not still not the best but like at least at least this
inner approval I'm gonna
go back to my own set I'm gonna like not even remember how
everything works
Holy shit.
Oh my god, it's a fucking...
Oh my god, what is going on?
It's a free fire.
It's a ward right now.
What the fuck?
Alright, who are we winning this?
Don't even know.
There's a lot of chaos.
At least servers are good.
I remember when...
Look at these tryhards, man.
i know right what the hell why are they playing meta have
some fun man this is a creator tournament be a creator
actually the music crypto bang axel that's just so weird
they got no morals at least play crypto fuse axel come on
yeah have some have some fun yeah goof gang with the second
with one kill
not he's helping play in the hard zone bro no he's actually
playing hard zone he's sitting back on slow games bro he's
he has another game on the second monitor that is crazy
he's like ping me when people start coming in crypto ban oh
oh what are you gonna play then mac you can't be up here a
little crypto ban they're trying to nerve you i get to play
the game your ipad no more no this is fantastic news for me
horrible for the lobby is that your feeling oh okay okay um
you can you can play some axle if you want i'll get on like
maggie or what else is open let me see what do i play i
gotta make sure my banner i gotta make sure my banner's okay
you have to make sure it's the plow badges yeah i gotta make
sure you know i gotta sell it you know kind of think i'm
gonna play some valve some valve axle fuse yeah we can
wait it gibby castle and caustic yeah and yeah i will not be
playing meat mountain we will not be moving we will not make
it i thought i saw i saw a tweet how gibby is faster than
octane now no oh yeah he's fast as boy yeah if you take yeah
that red stock you put it on a shotgun and then you take his
shotgun perk and you're literally so fucking fast you're
just flying that's actually the goofiest looking ever that's
like crazy his feet are just moving at mock 10.
the speed build well the fact that he's faster than octane
is wild to me like the man that's build for running and the
big chunky boy versus the big chunky man bro that actually
makes no crook's team is crazy what the are it's 57 points
probably just turned the content over again yeah but he
knows that all the loopholes is that no he fucking he
actually like wins all the creator attorneys oh shit he's
not winning this one today we're winning this one oh shit
today's that day yeah we're ending the streak now we're
ending his content we're ending that streak wait greek's
team's rank one in the group two who's his team greek vax
line and the praise it's a pretty good thing actually yeah
it is oh the six seven team is last though rest in peace
them there's a lot of people that might not qualify to this
bracket guys whoa phony might not call shiv and blast
saucers team honestly everyone in top like bottom like top
five right now can make not qualify if they have a zero
point yeah also if like people above them just stay alive
yeah exactly there's gonna be some upsets right now Ooh.
Is she joined Lobby Doki?
Oh, shit.
Oh, right.
I need to send you the code.
Yeah, I'm waiting for the code.
I was waiting for the...
Yeah, where's my code, guys?
Yeah.
So, okay, I'm not the last person.
It's all right.
Goop gang was taking a while, too.
Oh, goop gang was Jinji's team.
Yeah, they're not a Valk Rotate comp.
Wait, where are you going to play?
Mac we're playing Valk fuse axle all right oh yeah so the
idea is that I Valkal and it gives you guys wall hacks and
you guys axle Q forward hit people together and you fucking
murder them I see mm-hmm got this we got this now we have
another guy that you can actually shoot your gun this time
Mac yeah it's gonna be a good time he's not spectating
nigero now yeah i'm actually i've just been in the fucking
in the cuck chair the whole it's okay it's even worse
because you're what you're spectating other people's fights
too so yeah i'm just squidward looking out the window right
now is everyone's having a ball fighting outside man it's
okay at least i got to see that pov of your knuckle jump
worth it you know it really did what
team is crook on cbx oh that's why they're called cbx they
mean oh you meant like competitively no i meant oh no
competitively they're they're not they're not assigned team
um i don't even know what their name is or not i think their
name is brain rotting brain rotting are you talking about
kirk's team yeah yeah that was the team name for you ancy
you know kirk took the he took the 50 fuse perk game five oh
my god on accident it's because you know it's because he
misclicked it because we got thirded that was the game we
were on height dev coasts with everyone on baby comp it was
actually so tragic well that was where we went on you guys
yeah we would have killed every player in the lobby and how
we would have we would have killed you guys so freely but
skittle his valkal bugged and it like it did the slingshot
bug when you like detach but it did it to him like late as
hell yeah we're like it like teleports you to the side oh
yeah as we were landing on the silo and he just went flying
into gas and died oh i didn't even know that's three you
guys that's sad yeah i just got we could have actually one
club yeah sorting factory where we got the goat po we got
good shit yeah we got the goat oh my God it's wait actually
I'm gonna play blood out blood huh yeah yeah we're gonna
invisible slide on people what yeah you go invisible now and
what yeah you want what did they add that wait when did they
add that this patch this oh okay i was like i swear i played
last patch it's not good it's not good wait why are you on
bloodhound it's good for this comp it's good yeah it's good
all right okay okay it'll at least be funny yeah go comp
okay at least be really funny to kill someone yeah it'll be
content it'll be right yeah straight content if we kill
someone with this they're gonna be very mad just just be
careful with my scan because it can bait you because it does
like these snapshots like remember how old old what on your
sword yeah scan and it'd show you where someone was not
where they yeah it does that again oh the end of the scan ah
i see yeah so like it'll be live and then it'll go to the
snapshots and it can throw you off so just be aware of it i
see i see you know what i'm gonna do it i know you guys said
r9 is but i'm gonna do it i'm gonna do it i'm gonna do it
calls for me it's calling the prowler in the bag there's no
content on my arna right now it's just depression on the
arna but i want to know but i just found three arna it's
calling it's fate i found the siren song i got the car i got
the car
She's singing my name right now.
You got to tie me to the boat.
Yeah, pick it up.
Pick it up to Arnaud.
I want to see you experience the Arnaud Well, I got I had to
go all the way back It's okay.
We have a lot of time.
This is my green goblin mask.
It is it's cause for me I don't even know where I threw it
away.
Oh, I threw it here.
It's for the best
Okay, I have a rampage which I don't really want to fuck
with to be fair that thing with the red barrel is actually
pretty good i'm gonna grab the cvo there's a heavy thing
here we can hit that maybe they might they might fight in
stocks but one team's taking like forever to loot we could
grab this blue and then go third party at me all right done
i'm right behind you come on r3 car no sight looking for one
Now.
Nice.
Now this comp's even better.
I don't know if you can jump while you're in this.
I have no idea if that was.
So don't use it when you're in the.
He's going to throw a little bubble down.
So what Brodown does is it?
Throw the little bubble down.
You have to get into it.
Yeah.
And then we just run.
You can't use your ability though.
Okay.
I'll throw it right now so you can see what it's like.
You just jump in this.
Okay.
That's his ass.
Why are we...
And then you hit actually like this.
Well, I have to throw it on before.
And then we do it.
We're going to go for this evo to our left.
There's a blue light mag there.
Fighting here?
Yeah, I'm taking that.
Oh, shit.
I wish I had my own now.
Fuck.
Dude, that's my good timing.
Oh, shit.
That's on him.
That's our IGL right there.
This fight, we blame Album.
They're running right.
I'm grabbing this evo over here.
I'm not near you guys.
Yeah, you're fine.
Be careful of your ease.
the team might come from from our east coming towards me for
the single tear they're just sitting in building oh they're
rotating is that a joke they're trying to run up on me i'm
gonna back up a little bit i'm coming i'm coming careful
yeah i just put in i already jumped off but i think it's
like a hard edge team
left on the back of the building
They're just on the back stairs here.
I almost cracked the guy in the back.
I can...
One's on the right platform.
I'm needing them.
There's two there.
Two there.
I'm needing this guy.
120.
Oh, big name.
They're walking up.
There's no one.
They're so low.
Invis.
I'm going to hold them.
No, I troll.
Cracked one far.
Morales cracked.
Axel.
Oh my god.
One on your stairs.
Under your stairs.
Oh my god.
kind of hold your swing we're gonna get out of there yeah
yeah just try to dip out try to dip out or like i can't just
like tuck for a sec funk try to live yeah coming over to you
get up the hill maybe knock will jump out of there dokey you
have to get out i have to get out go up the hill yeah go up
the hill yeah go up the hill i'll shoot for you all right
i'm up the hill get all the way out i'm out like you and
then shoot for funk okay yeah i'm coming i'm coming out i
get there's There's people up the hill.
There's people up the hill.
You gotta live now.
You have to live for us.
Live for us.
You know, if only we had the invisible all of guys.
I did.
I used it.
Oh, you had the game already?
Yeah, dude.
I didn't know they had a mirage though.
I fucking was wide left and then this guy just started
hitting the carousel on me.
No, I started tweaking any mirage levels that I didn't know
what to do anymore.
Yeah, I didn't either.
I just died.
Yeah, you can.
Yeah, let's hope you don't.
You could go dumb.
Can I see how many my zoe?
Yeah, I have two of my kids.
I can do it.
It's only zone one, so...
Bro, I had the nastiest fucking jumps too.
It was not into enemy fire.
You actually don't have to help us.
I know!
I was like, oh shit, look at the sick ass movement, though.
Just for depression to hit.
Oh, now everybody's having fun.
I'm seeing some crazy fucking comps now.
Yeah, naughty and then they're dead.
Oh, they might not make it.
Who?
Goop gang?
Naughty in them.
Oh.
Oh shit, I saw that 360.
Don't worry, I got that on cam.
Yeah, it's actually- the board's hella tight.
They might not make it.
I can't hear anything in zone, bro.
I saw my audio gets like 20 times louder.
You have no meds for this?
Yeah, I'm gonna make it.
You guys can eat crap to make it.
Nah, I don't, unfortunately.
Do you want me to res you here or not?
I can just slide down and res you no name.
Yeah, yeah, just res us with sacks, like if a donut or
something.
Or if he gets shot down.
We'll be able to go back and like grab bodies too.
Alright.
Ooh, we're gonna go.
He's fast as fuck.
And we have a balloon yet.
We're chilling.
Oh shit, we're gonna be rich guys We'll be top 10 There's no
way we're not qualified There's no way we get out, right?
We somehow don't make it Yeah, it's like if you get
eliminated after top 10 to take away 10 points That'd be
crazy Oh, I think ship's team doesn't make it They just got
eliminated No Just take the balloon and go back to where
those bodies are going uh those teams probably all fought
there if they're still there then i'm just incredibly sad
and stand stupid let's just fight them if they're still
there yeah well oh i got my r9 yeah i mean i spawned with my
old yeah i spawned with my r9 yeah yeah blood on spawns if
they're old wait do you spawn to the os2 ducky no i admit my
r9 i got my r9 okay okay that's good that's good
I got my R9 guys, don't worry.
Do not worry.
No attached to my R9.
Yeah, I don't know what to do.
Don't worry.
Good review about that.
Oh, behind us.
I'm sorting.
Go home.
What the?
What is happening?
I'm in front of you.
I'm 38.
I'm popping my fuck at all.
I'm going.
I'm in there.
Oh my god.
I'm jumping into.
It's a fucking mirage.
No, I'm off.
I'm off.
All right.
No, I'm not fucking with the mirage, man.
We gotta go.
We gotta go the other way.
Yeah, no, I don't fuck with that.
That's a counter to pro players.
It actually is.
You see bodies and you're like, I want to shoot.
Oh, I fucked it up.
No, yeah.
You fucking, you pop the mirage hole in front of us and we
just go cross-eyed.
Okay.
Every single one of us.
It is my box.
The queues have seen better days.
Yeah, no.
I did.
it's because i'm i'm i'm not under pressure i'm not under
i'm not under pressure i'm not under pressure so i'm just
it's not like if it was a life or death situation i pull it
you know so we have this let's see if i have here real quick
there we go look at that yeah i got paid by r9 yeah yeah
yeah i need that get a nice white attachment on it You get
fucking nothing from them.
Yeah.
They actually make them spawn later and you don't get
anything from them.
Yeah.
It's like, what?
It makes no sense.
Guys, do not worry.
Here, here, Doki.
Oh, let's go.
Mazooka's out of that.
Max damage.
Let's go, guys.
Are you guys, like, good on loot?
I'm 2-10, but my guns are poor.
0-5, but...
I'm here.
Are you still on a rampage?
No, I took that out.
I got flatline.
There's a solo, like, I think, here on the...
He slid down.
Dropping a red barrel here.
Are you sure?
Wait, I don't have...
I can't put that on anything.
What are you talking about?
I wasn't sure if you had that rampage.
No, I have a flatline.
Okay, okay.
Somebody's going to look at my body and wonder why I have
this.
I think there's a rampart team set up in here.
Am I'm going to try to hold on to it, or...
Yeah, hold on to it.
No, you can drop it.
You can drop it.
honestly i'll take it back on our right on our right oh
should be on us on the on the well what the is that that's a
solo that's a story 40 man yeah yeah he's not truly solo
careful his humans are tower oh yeah yeah i see it coming
back oh yeah we should just back up yeah i'm out of heels
after this basically um i can give you a few cells that we
came from we're gonna go over here let's go i'm gonna be
zero zero zero zero one oh you popped your ult okay the
moment i did my we're rotating all right wait if you the
purple perk you you can use abilities and go re-invis i
think oh okay i took the other one i took the other one okay
that's why i'm still i i when i did the knuckle cluster jump
i i somehow passed through it i'm one cell and i have
nothing else that's a magazine over there not looking too
good here's a bat here's three cells i'll give you the bat i
took it just because i didn't I don't know if you have time
to do it.
It's okay, I can craft on.
They're evaking on their left guys.
There's a team on the icicles in front of us, careful.
Okay.
I'm just shooting at them.
We have West Meds there now.
Yeah, I do, I do.
Flying on us.
On our head, you're on our head.
We're on our head, you're on our head.
We can back up if we need, we can back up.
They're just on the head.
They're just sitting on the head.
I have a queue to go back.
Tell you a lot.
There was a team in.
We're getting drilled.
Okay.
Let's fuck off.
Yeah, I need to leave.
Follow me.
Do I get hit by that?
No.
We're just wrapping the left.
We're wrapping the left.
Let's rate this fucking...
He phased.
I'm about to get one tick by zone.
You can play to me.
Play to me.
Yeah, I'm trying.
I'm trying to walk up on the right.
They don't really have a spot.
I'm hitting him?
There's someone close left.
You got grab it.
Yeah, you got grab it.
Nice.
Yeah, we can.
Yeah, let's go.
Go.
I'm in there.
Just kill the shot.
Yeah, yeah.
Accident.
Crack, crack, crack, crack, crack.
Crack, crack, crack.
I'm gonna stop.
No, there he is.
I have.
Wait, there's a point.
Put it up.
Put it up, one of them.
Oh, I got hit.
I got hit.
One, one, one, one, one, one.
One, one, one.
He's healing.
Give me.
I don't have Q yet.
I have Q and one.
I'm just gonna pick it.
Live for us, Paul!
Live for us!
Live!
He fenced this portal and it got camped!
No!
It's getting a third in it.
They're also getting thirded.
What the hell?
Oh.
It's the fucking Gibby team.
Oh, they're dead.
They died for it.
They died.
Yo, that's fine.
There's six people that know it's a mirage.
The Mirage team's camping the fucking portal, bro.
Bro, who just fences the portal?
I know, right, who just fences a portal.
Oh, I'm watching the Mirage team now.
Wait, who's on Mirage?
Whose team is that?
Parasite.
I don't know any of these names.
Yeah, Parasite's the Mirage player.
We have Swag Million.
Oh, no, not Parasite.
I've only seen these name and ranked, I'm not gonna lie.
Swag million is the barrage, that's horror.
Yeah, I'm gonna say that's looking horror.
I should have just ripped that alt, honestly.
I didn't, I should have just tanked the shot and ripped it.
Oh my god, that Watts is playing for their life.
Wait, did Funk die or did you die when we slid the blood on
team?
I died first.
If you were alive, we could have fucking assaulted the Gibby
bubble.
Yeah, yeah, that's when I...
Okay, that's a great point.
Yeah, he poured into me, but I should have just saw her and
just ripped it all.
I shot her instead.
I was like, why did I shoot her?
I have a fucking bazooka.
My first instinct is to shoot.
three teams it's a repeat zone is it oh yeah it is here yeah
enemy there guys i think there's an enemy there is are you
watching enemy wait they're actually tweaking because
they're they were about to knock wall yeah they actually i'd
know they actually camped until they camped until They
literally camped, yeah.
Yeah, they have like one kill.
I mean, that's smart if you're not gonna, you know, Mac,
that is smart if you don't know if you're gonna qual or not.
You just go hide.
Yeah, Mac.
It's a pretty smart strategy.
Oh, wait, Med for my qual.
Phony my qual.
Yeah, they do off that.
Yeah.
Unless those other teams got a lot of points.
I just knew, I remember.
That rock is even out?
What the hell?
That is crazy.
I never saw that.
Ew.
I'm the Apex with P20s.
He's in the strong.
Might be.
Iron's naked hemlock with P20s.
Holy kid it.
The white laser and P20s just did that damage.
I could have red laser in my ship's not doing that.
Oh shit.
That looked more normal.
That looked more like what I'm shooting with the 20s.
Yeah, that gun is RNG.
I don't know how they lost that.
I mean they didn't get to shoot their guns majority of the
game so I don't think they were warmed up.
Actually they were probably playing a different game on the
side.
Enemy team's team qual.
Which teams qual?
I think not even might not make it off that game.
Wait not third place they got third.
That's what we're about to see in a second.
all right let's see come on take us back there hey i got to
shoot my r9 i call that a win i gotta shoot that r9 was it
feeling like a good r9 i don't know it happened so fast
literally the moment they died i another team rolled up yeah
i cracked someone they had to ruin our game i cracked
someone that's good enough I get to shoot my toy gun yeah
yeah that's last game I we qualify we're like there's no way
we don't qualify like oh that's phony's team missed by one
point oh it's not even them didn't make it oh no the one
point oh my god to a one-pointer no that that just happened
to them for for wait really one point yeah they missed out
on land by one point oh my god that's crazy are you talking
about to make finals no like to just to just to call land
yeah really just to call for land they lost to us by one
point that's crazy yeah
shiv didn't make it oh shiv's team got last oh they already
made the first round already made the new lobby already
that's fast this is a fast game oh my god i get to play
match point all right we have to stop memeing right at
training yeah we have to use my come out though Fuse might
come out again.
Fuse will come out.
It might be coming out again.
It might come out.
All right.
I can't promise you'll be playing it, but it'll come out.
Someone's going to be doing something on Fuse.
Oh, that's actually the one pointer.
That's actually crazy.
Hey, we're second guys.
We even won the tiebreaker.
Let's go.
yeah we might troll it on game three and four but that
didn't matter
yeah we got second i don't know you guys can access this but
here i don't know you guys can access this but this is uh
the ranking stuff it's okay guys i i get to exist
got two kills guys not to brag or anything but I got two
kills yeah I mean first place team third bronze player got
three kills but I got I got two for second place not to brag
or anything you know that is just pretty good those two
whole kills battered holy gamer so hum i know i'm so humble
hey some players i some players got zero but i yeah
yeah it's just it just be like that two more Wait, no,
seriously?
There's no two more kills than Greek?
No way, there's no way.
Oh, we have like seven more hours on me.
Seven minutes till it closes.
Two more kills than Greek.
That's crazy.
Go.
The code is out, Elbe.
Not to brag or anything, but it's two more kills than Greek.
Ha ha ha ha.
huh yeah I know pretty crazy pretty fucking wild
wait what am I playing I gotta make sure the bad banner is
correct it's gonna depend on our POI but probably Watson or
like maybe maybe cat maybe all right watson or cat maybe
caustic all right gotcha let me get these badges in i just
have to put flat badges on every character or not just in
case the wild card yeah do you play seer see yeah i played
seer before all right let me put that in
okay and then
sarcastic the fuck is god there he is
julian thank you for the super chat thank you thank you my
oh she is such a humble i know i know guys uh not toot my
own horn or anything but did you know i got two whole kills
in this tournament oh oh oh
do you guys know that oh i don't know just just just a
little reminder of how many kills i got i don't mean to brag
or anything but i was very important to my team as a very
important player
two two kills no way
i know zen needs that money which team is in the on um it
seems actually pretty good sednum panic fairy fair yeah but
i don't know when zed last last played this game so
oh but i'm having uh this is yeah we're at the we called we
called so um we have um we're playing match point finals now
so 50 points and up point time guys no more unfortunately no
more I know guys I know but we have to we have to hang the
fuse banner for today how is Timmy rogue and the Zack legal
does rogue even still play this game is he the is he their
plat player wait rogue is there fucking plat player that's
crazy i did not know that i thought what did he do now apex
he plays battlefield oh does he he fully swapped to red
slack the would be whatever did it work um
it supports what you mean like work like yes and followed
yeah like he you know like when you change out of your your
you know your niche you're gonna lose viewers that's yeah i
mean he's still successful he's still successful yeah he was
like he was like 2k-ish 2k or more usually on apex he's like
500 600 on red sex yeah that's all that he can you know red
sex is like pretty dead oh
he's doing okay but as far as i know the game is not it's
okay now he's plat now he's plat though now he gets to be
plat i was gonna i was like rogue is there i i saw the team
i was like is that rogue frog I was like, oh my, that's a,
that's a loophole team right there.
That's a good loophole team.
Yeah, they're definitely cheating the system.
He is not a plot player.
It's okay.
We are too.
A few, a few other teams are, so we can't feel bad.
Yeah, we can't feel bad.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Who's a real plot team, honestly?
Which, is there real plot teams?
Honestly, probably winning.
team nine team nine good for them is gold one good for them
they made it flat two flat two 59 000 kills on watson or
maybe that's apex kills in total oh that's 59 on watson oh
that's that is a lot yeah that's a lot of kills you're
playing in my backyard maybe it's wolfie
who's there okay i don't even know which who's their actual
player the pro player is cool yeah i don't know is wolfi
their plat player is it phantom you're playing no idea i
don't know like some of these people yeah i'm not that like
i'm kind of just like apex and that's it some marvels and
stuff too yeah good for them they beat shiv's team you know
good for it they beat phony's hey they beat a few good teams
phony's team was very good like also a loophole team?
Assault metaphor.
I don't know who assault metaphor are.
That was your old team.
Wait, Matt, that was your old team.
That I put.
Yeah, it was.
Wait, your old team?
I accidentally poached him.
It was supposed to be me metaphor and assault.
But if he was like, hey, I was like, are you in this
tournament?
And if you left the team, It's okay.
I think it was a very good decision.
I mean, you called.
We're having a great time.
We're having a great time You they wouldn't have done the
few shit.
I've done, you know Exactly.
Yeah, you got your clip.
That'd be way too serious over there.
That's not fun
All right, speaking of serious lock the fuck in it's we're
lock in it's match point finals To win two million dollars.
Let's go.
Yeah We're on fucking land right now we're fist bumping
going into this game we are first time all of us first time
winning a match point final let's go i've won them before
recently it was a while ago yeah
we're like the best hard zone poi yeah and there's nobody
fragment holy what do i i hope i'm not first choice because
it's gonna be bad for us first choice but then where I got
it it was next to Watson thank God
it's probably going to be an altar band this game if people
are smart they'll probably all play crypto and altar but
we'll see see how it goes we might see some weird shit yeah
jelly and then we're probably going to play Axel uh Doki
land on the middle here there's bins on the back side loot
those bins loot the height and then loot the two bins here
and then go for the console all right there's no end i might
take like the north yeah yeah i'll just really have this
whole construction building all right i won't call the r9
you forgot that the was back yeah you need to get off
deadlock asap no i'm kidding you guys been talking about oh
wait there's no building here anymore there's a five stack
here now the i low-key it was weird when i first saw it god
i just found on our head dokey oh no okay console as soon as
you can actually it looks like a sorting zone i'm heading we
want to get out of here pretty quick even worse sorting zone
man funk just start pathing towards her and then dokey when
funk gets here you'll pop that balloon and we'll just get
moving like just loot around a little bit after you hit it i
discovered the All right, got it.
There's a fucking harvester zone.
That's probably better.
Yeah, I'm looting this and I'm coming.
I'm ready to go.
I'm going to be longbow prowler.
I'm sentinel prowler.
Oh, I'm car prowler.
Let's go.
You can have my sentinel.
No, it's all right.
It's it's all right.
All right.
Let's go.
You like push.
You like push?
Just walk up and press it, yeah.
On the console thing.
There's a lot of sites here if you need.
Yeah, just land on that Eva.
Yeah, I got you.
Oh yeah, we're good.
We can land on that.
We're gonna go into Harvester here.
Yep.
This is a weird zone.
It definitely pulls back though.
Yeah, I think it's a lava one.
Like, we want to put like the south leg if we can.
Yeah.
Go.
all right i almost got a tp we got this i'm so confident we
can get that south light we want more traps right yeah you
want more traps i could almost feel the upgrade course i
think someone just i don't know what i saw i saw something
southwest i can drone into it the others there's a guy in
the bottom middle right now i mean traps are i getting in i
could put it you have a serious scan do we got serious scan
careful funk you can you can cross up into that room and get
your TP.
Yeah, it's for you.
Do you have TP?
Yeah, I do.
I do.
I hear someone on the outer ramp, I think.
There's someone joining it.
Someone joining it.
Oh, that's you.
You're good.
I'm about to put it down.
Maybe we're going to EMP push those.
I got seagrote from low ground.
Yeah, you're good.
You're good.
There's a team low ground already, okay?
Seagrote him.
All right.
Ducky, take my sentinel so you can actually shoot people
from far away.
Do you want the car or the prowling?
Wait, wait, wait.
There's a sentinel here.
There's a sentinel here, guys.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
We got an extra one.
Oh, yeah.
And I'll just play iron side sentinel.
Take the 3x.
I'm getting undone.
Just get barrels down, like one on each door, one like down
here.
Yep.
Well, goodbye.
Oh, we're fine.
Get one.
like here dorky like on one of these pillars so that
triggers if they try to walk up because they can be on that
door so like be careful all right you can craft bats here if
you guys need as well come throw a barrel towards the middle
here okay well give me a second blob them really far you
should be able to throw it from the front door i'm waiting
until i have four seconds first blood the cycle has become
does anyone have a do you have a heavy mag up or no no i'm
literally just red dot prowler and then iron sight sentinel
i am actually just on piss yeah now my way It's a bit of
bad.
Oh, I'm glad.
I just wanted to craft that.
Looking for you, I'm looking for you.
Trying to see what comp this team is down here.
Looks like Alter C or Caustic down here.
You can get one barrel here if you want.
All right.
But if we get EMP'd, all your barrels will disappear.
But let's hope that doesn't happen.
It's gonna happen, but you can- Trying to thermite our door
off where you go to Bob.
Playing Cier instead of Cier.
Oh, there's a wingman here.
Yeah, yeah, there's two Ciers near us.
Do you stay at this door for me?
I'm gonna grab this one.
Yeah, I'm sorry.
He's gonna peek it.
They have white armor.
This is so cool, boy, later.
All right.
I might be able to just insta-kill one soon.
I mean, they just have cats, so they're gonna stall, but...
Yeah, we can't really...
We don't have hemlocks to breach, so...
I can queue through, though.
If only we had a fuse.
I'm actually just gonna...
Yeah, right.
I'm gonna play up a little bit.
Try to get a...
Yeah, you can play...
the middle i'll i'll go i'll get in drone on your tp so i
can recall you if need me i heard a new team new team e
might be a close guy if he does that again i did not expect
to be there i think our spot will be better than theirs i
don't think this one's leaning west okay yeah he's just
scoping into that door waiting for me to peek it okay your
your job while we sit here is just think about like i'll be
thinking about it already but try to think about like what
kills us and pay attention to that kind of like area all
right find find our thoughts think about think about threats
be anxious all right be paranoid they're all out to get you
make sure on the right walks up someone's coming out here
somewhere yeah there's a drone drone right now i don't want
should i shoot that that alters him you can break it break
it if not it's not really a big deal i don't think we're
gonna be able to increase on Irma I can heal armor you don't
have to heal your armor either and done it'll automatically
you oh yeah you're rude John yeah feel free to like peek and
just shoot everybody close here yeah on the ramp he's
fucking off I'm gonna come back
there's a team over there this guy's playing back out on
this ramp here yeah I'm gonna go to calm but Doki mostly
just pay attention to the inside walk up from this team.
Because we're not on the bin out here.
Just grab some stuff.
I'll look down here then.
Yeah.
Just pay attention to that.
Make sure they don't try to like sneak up from the inside.
I'll pay attention to our outside.
All right.
I'll look down then.
I was subject to view.
Far off.
They are fucking beefing out here on my red bang.
I don't think you can see that though.
I'm gonna look for cousin for that actually.
I'm not sure.
You might be able to catch someone in the back here.
Yeah, maybe.
Also just jumped off.
I don't know, 60 from building team.
I don't see him right here.
The snake is fighting.
Funk, you can see this guy here, maybe?
Well, I can see this guy.
Oh.
Cracked one?
These guys are tweaking.
There's a solo altar from the height fucking with these guys
in the snake.
He's recalling back to height now.
They're not even opening the door.
It's a different one.
These guys are still alive.
They're so scared.
yeah I mean two teams are really really bad oh they're
looking they opened the door and saw me and closed it just
don't want to get where I walked up on yeah that's what I
our number one threat is I'm just walking up through an
inside tube yeah there's a queue here through the there's
two guys oh my god they three to one looking for you yeah
yeah you can beat from me That's like the best we've been
going.
All right.
108.
Oh, a classic one.
No.
They wasted their gas.
They're really bad down there.
I might look for it to kill them.
You might just want to kill them.
All right.
I guess I'll shield cell then.
I can regen.
Just regen.
Just bomb a wrench.
Do you have an aid album for the door and I can just wrap up
one of them?
I have an aid.
Yeah, I do.
If you can aid this door on the right.
I'm waiting for this cost to go up.
Throwing grenade.
I might have fucked that.
Might be a little short.
That's short.
They have to see it.
That's the only issue.
Well, I can see their crypto.
They don't have a crypto.
Oh, maybe not.
I'm tipping back up so I don't get it in.
There's two on the head.
Yeah, I can probably get a kill.
They have white armor.
I just need to hit one headshot and like go on.
I mean, on zone flip, if zone pulls down, If it like pulls
with like the edge overlapping down here and we're not in,
we're just going to hit the fuck out of this team down here.
I opened my door.
This guy in the middle don't know.
right now we're here's too far Zoki you can see that guy
from the door yeah I can see him open yeah I know I'm just
fucking with him you have to be careful like from this door
because they might like swing this middle area oh okay yeah
yeah I thought you were saying hi to me I was just seeing
how I bet I thought you were saying hi to me I was not that
friendly no it's a creator tournament i thought he was gonna
say hi to me no man they all want you dead i just told you
to be paranoid no bro someone's coming up we're good i
thought we could be friends here one bro i'm gonna kill
these guys soon okay ducky sorry do we just want to work
this do you think it's like i think it's kind of no i think
it's kind of hard yeah they're gonna get yeah they're gonna
get fought on next zone not like this flows with the one
after this you get 100% there's some series.
It's kind of annoying Yeah, I mean it'll be free later.
We just kind of sit on our hands and then kills will come to
us It's gonna be the zone that's leaning.
It's the lava one.
I think that I called initially.
Yeah, no, no, no, you're over here We're like the rocky
shit's hot.
Yeah, you're definitely right.
We're gonna get a lot of kills here I'm getting scanned from
southeast.
I think oh no, I'm getting scanned from west.
Oh, it was northwest It's yeah, it's a team in the choke
here.
Doki you can shoot these guys from our door We'll just
standing in the open here.
Yeah, I see it.
They're no longer standing your feet when you guys need this
i wish i got that four by six i have three i have four
i have four okay do you need bats i have one i'm sure it's
fine there's a bow right here you just dropped take this
other one too oh my god we'll need them more than that
you're good just heal your heal your flesh you rejoined made
from middle yeah you're already pushing i'm looking no we're
gonna go
he's just flexing out he's he's not even the team from over
here he's the team from the Northeast ramp this Northeast
ramp team is someone good with the way they're playing all
right that altar is playing really confident
everybody so
everybody throw a barrel at the store which door it should
start burning on our back here soon maybe this cereal I
don't know what out a little bit?
Like, try to get some barrels, like, around here, like on
the walkouts.
Maybe your barrels is alarms.
Don't walk out.
You can throw them from far.
Yeah, you can throw it hella far.
Oh, let somebody get shot there.
All right.
It's ours.
That's as far as I could throw.
Yeah, that's good.
These guys are crossing on the right here, am I thinking?
I'm looking at them.
They're crossing to the left.
One's on the rock.
We're in a god spot, but we're going to get fucking inted.
We are inside the next.
Really bad.
I mean, we could take, can we put a height?
No, no, no, just get more barrels here.
Just put like two barrels here.
Get one in the donut funk.
Work with her.
Help her take some space.
Yeah, we need to like put barrels.
Yeah, yeah.
You should be able to walk out a little bit.
Okay, it's on the ground, never mind.
This guy's dropping under us right now.
Yeah.
They're gonna try to play under our ramp.
I can look the key on him.
Yeah, yeah, you definitely can.
I'm gonna look for him.
These are there.
He's just, he's just rolling.
He's destroying.
He's going for the roof.
Yeah.
I'm gonna try and throw it again.
I see.
Oh my god, I hit the fucking wall.
Yeah, look for KP on that.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm gonna walk out middle.
Yeah, Doki, move with Funk.
Move with Funk and get more barrels down in the middle.
Okay, okay, okay.
We just need to like get a barrel on my red ping on this box
here.
Okay, I got one.
This guy in the low ground here, Doki, you can look at him.
I'm walking around.
Check and turn around.
Look at this.
Yeah.
There's a guy right here.
Okay.
Killed one.
He's under the ramp here.
Just shoot him off.
Play towards our building, Doki.
Play towards our building, not in the middle anymore.
Got another kill.
Nice.
There's a solo crypto under here maybe?
Doki, put a barrel on this ramp.
You'll gas them on their walkout.
Put it right here and then just into the cockpit.
Oh, I can't.
Funk, this team might try to queue up on us with the MP.
I'm coming back.
I will see your own is on my ping.
Break their drone, Doki.
I'm going to really, I will.
Where is it?
He cut me.
He cut me up here?
Doki, peak on this pipe and throw it to gasplate here.
I have a good name.
Just wait.
This way.
Gasplate on your corner.
Okay Kake.
Really good name, really good name.
They queued me.
So much damage.
You can get us.
I got it, got it, I got it.
Yeah.
They cut it back.
They died in the gas.
They're done in the gas.
Paik the pipe, Doki.
Peek the pipe.
There's another team under here.
Yeah, they impede.
We're good.
I knocked one.
Oh, the other team knocked him.
Just keep looking for KP.
The guy, my guy.
There's one more guy on the team.
He's below me.
I'll be the solid below me.
Keep working now.
There's still one more.
There's still one.
He is.
Where below you?
I think I got KP.
I got on this side on my ping.
Like under the ramp on that other side.
There's no one here.
There's a team over here though.
We're still in.
We have a god spot.
I got one of them, but I don't...
There's a team here you can shoot.
I'll throw one, I'll throw one.
Yeah, look at that one.
There's a rat here.
There's a rat.
I'm like, I see him.
108.
Careful, fine.
Come back up.
I'm good, I'm good.
He's behind a knockdown here.
Doki, can you throw barrels at him?
Just log barrels in from the pipe?
You can take that cue up if you need it.
Just really give us some fuck.
I just got killed from the east.
I might be walking up.
Oh, fuck.
I'm watching our east now.
You guys keep, just try to get the kill on that rat.
I'm going to white swing it.
I'm not going to love you.
You should be able to just kill him with gas, Doki.
Oh, I got it.
That's a down.
It's a down guy.
It's a down.
I got it.
I got the kill.
It's behind the boxes.
I got it.
He left.
I don't know where he went.
Might be inside.
There's players in this.
I'm gonna try to look this real quick.
There's players here.
There's a drone here.
You guys need anything?
I broke the drone.
I need heavy.
I only have 35.
I only have 35 bullets heavy.
Where is Matt?
Oh, there you are.
Come back up before I get scanned.
Hey, I'll drop in a mag.
I have all things up for y'all.
You have heavy?
I'm like, do you have ammo?
I'm gonna have ammo.
Look for kills.
Yeah, walking in here.
Yeah, yeah, free kills.
Free kills on that.
I'll suck.
I cracked one.
Get some gas down on them.
I'm getting an agent.
You can get gas on me.
Doki, you're muted.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh shit.
There's no gas trucks on here.
They're right here.
I'm trying to throw it.
They might keep the wall.
Okay, they might keep to the wall.
We're amy.
You're just breaking my gas.
Doki, Doki, you're not in.
Oh, shit.
You're in here.
I'm here.
Come back to this here.
There's a duo out here.
They're knocked.
No, no, you're not.
Okay, okay.
We need to kill this team under us.
Can we, can we get ready?
Get ready to prep this.
I will.
We're going to queue down on them with EMP and gasnate,
okay?
Okay.
You out the wall right now, Doki.
I'm going to EMP after my EMP, you gasnate.
Okay.
I'm going to queue right here.
Don't kidnap me.
Oh!
You got kidnapped by the team.
I got kidnapped.
I'm EMP.
Just send it.
Fun.
Yeah.
I didn't even realize I can get kidnapped here.
I'm sorry.
I didn't realize where you were placing that.
No, they did it.
Oh, they kidnapped me?
Nice, Funk.
Okay, Funk, there was a team inside, a team on the roof, and
then the team under our ramp, but there's a solo somewhere.
If you find him, you can get there.
I think he's on the east.
I don't know.
Down the roof, you inside.
I think inside is great.
So what's this other one inside?
Oh, that was not a solo.
That was not.
It's not good.
Bro, I just wanted to get that Moby down somehow, bro.
I think he's on the opposite side.
I think I had a double Q2, maybe.
Oh, it was Bronzy's team.
I didn't know.
It's two duos.
It's one full team, two duos.
I think so.
Oh, my God.
The fucking kidnap.
Oh, I should have stood against that.
That's just unfortunate.
It's not good.
Am I high?
It was 310.
No, I'm high.
I'm high.
My math is actually cooked.
It was 410, right?
So it's 410.
I'm just actually just bricked in the head.
No, you're good.
That's okay.
It's okay, guys.
I got two kills, guys.
I'm happy.
No, definitely not.
You put that down and you're just getting into it.
If there's no seer, then it's like, that's a doable game.
They're like, get a top two, but...
okay so everyone full team bro what the fuck why did we do
that what what happened to you was they circued you and then
they just fucking kidnapped you to the floor that's crazy
that's that's cyber bullying it only works like that because
they're technically under us that's fucking cyber bullying i
was the plot player
so smart though that's actually so smart i couldn't even we
should have played off for this left side huh did you think
i don't know or no i couldn't have played for this left side
fight i didn't know i wasn't sure about the left just
because like the left there's like the team is playing the
east rocks the whole time yeah no you're right it's like
yeah that fence up yeah it's fine you probably could have
played it under the ramp and been fine the worst place i
could i had my cue out too but i couldn't even chuck it
because it killed me so fast i would have just fucking i
would have like suicide bomb that if i could you're probably
still silenced yeah i was i was i was ready i couldn't press
it it's gonna take them down with me i should have swapped
my gun at the end i would have killed that whole team all
taking me across i just had a long bow at the end that would
have been smart all right i'm sorry we saw yeah yeah that
was a beautiful game yeah that was a good game for us i'm
just saying i wanted to maximize bronzey with the 14 kills
damn yeah that's just like seer crypto that comp is so good
like it depends what po you get but oh i see they're like
speed running to to fucking matchpoint it's okay they're
gonna slow down here i believe they're not winning out
matchpoint we're not let that happen we're gonna make sure
we're gonna remember their skins remember their uh go gonna
remember every skin by heart we see them we just ruin their
game get three shows okay wait I need to use the bathroom
I'll be right back because yeah me too I'll be back beer me
chat bathroom time I have to hydrate a lot
alright I'm back uh stuffed on Gab's Broku Duck Cyber Papa
Zuka thank you listen for chatting thank you thank you hope
you guys have been enjoying uh the games so far um been a
while since i streamed apex too but i've been having a lot
of fun with my team i think that's all matt matters we've
been doing pretty well too yeah matt cooked with this team i
was like all right you want to join he's like sure and oh
it's because i streamed 10 hours guys i don't know you guys
know this but talking for 10 hours straight is not very is
might not be like ideal
it might not be ideal but it's okay yeah oh it's oh was it
i'm sorry i've lost count after 10 clearly after 10
everything blurred together so i was i streamed rivals for
maybe 12 hours straight guys
All right, give me a sec.
Did they make the new lobby yet?
I think, oh, fresh time.
I don't think so.
I think there's still, like, I think it's, like, break time
or some shit.
Oh, no, they're all here.
Whoops.
Everybody's here.
I was like, it's break time.
Nope, they're all here.
Oh yeah 14 including the scrims that I didn't stream that's
so true so true I'll keep baited your shell axe and Alb yeah
you said I and then you just I didn't know what you were
talking about for some reason no what I did was bricked
anyways but I mean yeah low-key I was fucking dead if I
should have done no no you're good bro I should have if you
had a movie on you we could have fucking I got a movie from
the boxes there's like 19 boxes in the ravine yeah lava yeah
what i did was what i did was fried but they're probably
gonna queue in on us anyways with sierra oh no we were dead
yeah i think fourth would what uh what that was probably our
best place man yeah yeah you got you got best case scenario
they're playing your life and killing the outside scores
aren't oh now they're updated they're not updated yet we're
just chilling right now it's hanging out
altar ban what
are we doing now what's the strat what were you doing now
what's the strat uh probably just wraith crypto and uh a
constant character just put funk on the wraith why am i why
am i on one of the console characters probably caustic again
all right let's go it worked it was working I got two old
kills that's two kills more than you Mac
He's actually an iPad with 20.
I only EMP'd once, too, that whole game.
I was just sat there just watching everybody have fun.
Yeah.
Could have been you.
You would have been an active that game if I actually had a
better gun at the end.
If only I knew how to play crypto, guys.
I don't know if this PY is good anymore.
This used to be climatized.
It's good.
Yeah.
Okay.
It spawns pretty good, though.
It's like better than climb I might have been in depends on
the RNG, but okay, Doki boy Seer Seer?
Okay, where is he?
I see him.
Axel, Axel.
Last choice.
Oh fuck.
It's fine, it's fine.
This still works.
Wait, what was Axel supposed to play?
Oh wait, what was I supposed to play?
Axel?
Axel.
Yeah, but it's fine.
This comp works too.
Oh!
And then they're gonna ban Alter after.
I hope maybe someone DCs.
Wait, what if I DC and then force a...
I'm like, oh no, guys.
I DC.
They have, like, trials here.
I'll, like, there's, like, little trials things.
I can spawn, like, amps and...
I don't know.
I'm just going to take this top left corner.
Wait, what?
I'm going to...
Everyone lay there.
Just, like, four corners.
Just land a corner.
A lot of...
I'm in the center.
That works.
It would be a shame if I just DC right now.
Oh yeah, I already got an M.
Pretty good.
Nice.
I think it's like one of the better PIs than Rodex for sure.
I really hope so, considering what we had here before.
Wait, I've never been this rich before.
Yeah, I think this is better than Kama.
I'm not gonna lie.
What the fuck?
I actually have loot.
It's crazy.
They added these like places on the map called honeypot
zones in the fucking in the files and they just have all the
best loot on the map in it for some reason.
Let's see.
And each map has like four of them.
So I guess this is one of them.
Actually, there's a flat line here and he wants it.
I'm good.
I'm flat line probably now.
I'll limit to Emma.
Oh my god, a purple backpack.
Oh, I might run that actually.
I don't think I'm limit to Emma, wingman.
I don't think I've seen a purple backpack before.
I jumped the X over armor.
I can take the over armor.
There's another purple.
Oh my, this PY is so good.
We're like millionaires.
Yeah, exactly.
It's our first time seeing loot the whole day.
Oh my god, it's so true.
You guys who won't?
I just need a prowler if you see one.
I have one and I can trade you what he has.
I have a car.
I can play on car if you want, prowler.
It doesn't matter to me.
I'm not you know, I'm gonna make up.
I dropped a blue heavy mag.
Does anyone like mag want that?
I got I have one.
I'm gonna need that.
I'll take that from my car.
I'll switch that We got a moby I was gonna say for Geline
doors, but we men still get on race yeah Move my drone up
here start getting up the hill.
We can maybe kill this war camp team if they come for the
C-Vah and then they're like crypto.
Coming over.
Yeah, I'm walking up.
They're over here still.
What do I want?
I don't want to like run at them, but you want the
regenerative gear.
It's bugged and it silences people for double duration.
Double right, double right perk.
Just pick the double right ones.
You get every time you scare someone, you get a shield, like
one shield.
Oh, what?
Yeah.
Yeah, and then it silences them for 10 seconds instead of
five.
Oh, okay.
It's not supposed to do that.
I think these guys rotated up here.
It's been doing that for two months.
Oh, are you sure it's not his feature at that point?
Like, generally, why are you talking about the best team
ever made, bro?
Can't do that.
That feels like a feature of that.
There's like problems they didn't fix that were still in the
patch.
Yeah, that's one of them.
OK, they're kind of beefing over at grandma's.
Yeah, what's going on there?
Oh, looks like that team is just leaving.
It didn't even fully look there if you are.
Let's, I'm going to grab this EVO with drone and then let's
go east towards Overlook.
There's a prowler over there.
I'm not coming over there.
Wow, okay.
I'll just play car, that's fine.
I technically, I'll can pick it up.
I won't shoot my gun.
I can pick it up because I have a car ready.
Oh yeah, just take it and then we can trade if you want.
We're going to go east after this, go grab this EVO, see if
we can look for that carepack and monument.
It's already taken.
It's already gone.
Yeah, it's gone.
i'm coming over here backing out of my throne i'm good to go
i have an evac as well though we're gonna look for that
we're gonna go that way and look for the evo or the yeah the
evo anyways come on i'm ready to trade whenever i'm next to
you okay drop drop okay there's a cell over here running
into us we're gonna kill that guy yeah let's go kill that
guy have a cool skin on that gun for you well everybody's
just fine Let's go kill this guy north.
Jockey, come.
Okay.
Just solo here.
We just crafted.
You want me to evoke?
Yeah, if you have to.
Yeah, I'm just gonna do it.
I'm heading over to you.
Right behind you.
He's resident over here.
I'll be back in.
You're very alone right now.
You're very alone.
Okay, you're very alone.
I'm gonna do this on my drone.
I'm gonna EMP when they come out.
He's going up to the hill.
I'm gonna land on the hill.
Me MPing.
I'm landing on the hill.
I have a really good shot for him in a second.
Melnited in front of me.
Ray Faze.
I'm right behind him.
Nice.
Ray three in zone to my left, I think.
Yeah, Ray's on me.
I'm with you.
Up to my right.
He's up here.
Let's get him.
I see him.
He's on the wall on the outside.
On my thing.
I hear...
I scan him.
I saw his heartbeat right here.
He should be somewhere over there.
He's out here.
you're very weak he's running along the wall yeah i see him
he's right here he's right here right here right here i'm
gonna he's running through the road here up here problem i'm
healing i
don't see heartbeats yet he's out of gas now i think he's
phased he's running up so far holy shit oh influence just
saved him you have two bats on my bottom as well they're
Yeah, they're here.
I dropped there.
Oh.
Well.
You pick up mine.
Thank you.
Fucking drone.
He can craft monument again.
I'm going.
Yeah, just balloon on him.
I'm gonna go hit the IV for us.
Just run that fucker down.
Yeah, yeah.
He has to go to the respawn beacon.
I don't think he can get Moby.
I'm right behind you.
I'm just waiting for scan.
I didn't get to hit it.
Alright.
Told myself going up the balloon.
I think I just heard him here.
Doki, scan around with your hands.
I'm scanning, I'm scanning.
I don't see him.
If you have a sight, you can scan for that, okay?
If you have a sight on your gun, you're long range.
Yeah, I don't see any footsteps.
He's in here.
He's res in.
I forgot that was a res building, bro.
Oh, I think they get it though.
I don't know if we can fight that.
Yeah, they get it.
We go east.
off though so it's gonna we're gonna glory for our games
together i'm not gonna lie i was only looking for this res i
forgot about that one dropping an extra barrier you can get
it
i don't see any footsteps
dropping a grenade here i have a billion frag grenades by
the way i have three they're on high yeah
yeah he goes really far out of the way we one and then path
him through sorting okay a lot of teams yeah i mean people
are gonna do stupid shit so we're mostly just like playing
to run down the clock and plays on his own all right yep i'm
gonna hit this uav and know him for us keep going up the
hill yep should be able to grab this evo go into sorting get
that uav and get our final evo there too sorting but on this
one like for what it looks like i kind of doubt it yeah it
looks chill for now i don't hear any heartbeats yet you know
how like seer fully works right like the blue scans and when
i see the little yellows do you know those blues too there's
blues yeah when you see blues i mean there's someone beyond
75 meters okay yeah no i see you yeah okay scan with your
site and if you have like a 3x or a 2x4 it's goes way
farther yeah I only have a 2 yeah 2 still really no 2x4 no I
got just two all right you didn't drop it on the right yeah
I thought you're gifting it to me I was like oh nice don't
think you want 2x car one guy in front of us yeah that's
cool over there he's on the height i think he jumped he
jumped there's a team coming in we're gonna grab we're gonna
grab i yeah i see the blues funk funk run a tp to the donut
run a tp to the donut we can take that and just see if we
can get you can kill them maybe yeah there's there's blues
to my left and right
let me know if we if i can insta-take yeah you can take it
they seriously they're like on the rocks here could be on
bridge as well you're going back into gas we need a shot
from bridge on the left careful inside yeah no tracks yeah
i'm going back one's dead one's knocked i know i need to get
one i'm just heading to get back i'm just going back to
where this guy camps us yeah i have old excel yeah yeah here
goes where i can give you nades you have a lot of room yeah
i have so much room
All right, that's all I can care.
I have sticks now.
Doki, you want nids?
No, I got a lot of nids too.
Yeah, I'm going to hit the CIV.
I'm just going to drone for it a little bit.
They're playing like one guy in this snake.
I can probably kill this guy.
I'm going to look if there's one more slightly beyond him.
Doki, move with him.
Wherever funk goes, go blow yourself to him.
They just got on drone.
They're scanning us.
They're like in the snake portion, like on the bend.
Once close on your left door.
Yeah, my door.
You see on me?
They're on both doors.
Yeah, I can EMP them.
They're gonna see what instill in EMP.
But you can just do it for now if you want.
I need the door on the right-off.
We could bait there, you'd so.
Walk up on the left.
Yeah, he's on the door on the left.
You can hit it.
Walk up outside on the left.
Come.
I see you in the left.
walk out left yeah my left my left he's just trying to hit a
scan and then he's gonna swing off the compound might be
free over there bro the pill resets not looted yeah I think
it's free I can't tell yeah I'm gonna try to rotate with you
I don't see any heartbeat is there I didn't see any
heartbeats no heartbeats I just can't get the bubble I
actually don't know if I'm gonna make this hold up.
Oh, look.
Someone joined me.
Show on the low for the worst.
I should be good.
It's shot, it's shot, it's shot.
You might get shot when you come out, but it's pretty safe.
We're not in.
We're like hard showing.
I think we're showing on the left here.
Okay.
I'll check.
I'm going to show on this box.
No heartbeats.
Not yet.
You're good on me.
If you play out on me, we're really good.
Just like so behind these boxes and stuff.
These guys are playing out on their roof.
and shoot at us the guys that we were like offering to fight
before he's not very careful be careful of this this angle
if this yeah there's a team up here there's seven teams in
here i see the heartbeats you can play down here this is
like really decent space yeah head glitch and shit i need to
see what the space underneath these guys looks like i
honestly do not remember it's like the same is that so many
heartbeats around this is different is it yeah yeah team
like here's like not far far though far from here we can
play this walk in through the low ground i think we
literally just walk against the cliff side and i think we'll
be okay we have like a rock for cover from our left and and
like tree should fight i hear heartbeat in this general
direction but like blue heartbeats okay they're fighting
here fun let's walk along the bottom or something oh i got
gray bread or something try to get healthy ducky ducky slide
forward on me okay they're We just slide down and play
against the wall under here and then we can run a TP in
third party.
I have TP in five.
Am I kidding?
Yeah, this third party is actually perfect.
Holy shit.
The spot is on me.
You should be perma safe.
Pretty straight has Kramer on high.
Yeah, I have to queue you guys.
Hold up.
Hello.
They're right above me.
I'm queue, but I'm portal.
I can support all over.
It's a knock.
They're cleaning up right now.
and don't fall down at all right it's one full full three
and then another one is like you're resetting inside play it
slow don't pop your DPI yet just wait okay I'm waiting okay
they're not there's cores or on they just knocked on start
walking in right here take portal instantly don't you take
portal instantly we're going to kill us zero zero so short
immediately I'm down I'm dead I'm done om on back oh my god
I hope we can rise up oh You're going to get in the portal.
You're going to be.
Yeah, you're going back in the portal.
Good luck.
Oh, what?
Bro, there's a guy outside right, man.
I just fucked up.
No.
We got Kramer.
Black chat eliminated.
Just got P20 gapped so badly.
I just got double sales, man.
The wraith was outside.
P20, man.
Yeah, I got, I got Kramer.
Craybird where was this area was there even a safe spot to
res no right uh not if that guy jumps down uh because I was
gonna say like should I just stuck should I've like waited
before I stuck the res no it looks like I got a jump so
they're gonna they're gonna clear us I see it didn't run all
too out of there I don't even know what up a portal there
either because this guy's just Oh,
they're running.
That team's gonna...
That team's zipping.
Oh, they're running.
Oh, the fuck!
It's okay.
The team that killed us also died.
So like...
It's like karma.
This team...
Which team...
I gotta just out one way, Zach.
He was hitting that.
Oh shit, what the fuck?
Oh, they got the res?
No, no, they died.
They died.
What team is this?
I'm- oh, yeah, we're watching two different teams, right?
Because you guys died to a different one.
I'm watching Sonny's team.
Yeah, yeah, we're watching two different teams.
We got- do we got points?
TP?
Yeah, we got two.
We got two.
Yeah.
two goes two is better than no not just does 13th place get
one point or what's the placement top 15 is one point and
then top 10 is two points all right that's good enough good
enough for me i'm gonna get water at that point i don't even
know where to dig in probably about like two three minutes
watch your back i won't always be around
Could be a crypto ban for you though.
I hope so.
Yeah.
It'd be pretty good to get that character out of here.
Crypto, Crypto, Crypto, Crypto, Crypto, Crypto.
No, Syra actually might get banned.
No, that should be crypto, yeah.
Definitely crypto.
I'm back, guys.
Many, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
TRI, thank you, but welcome to Tomato Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Welcome.
Who won?
Team Team Liquid.
That's good.
Team Liquid.
That's a good one.
Thank you guys.
All right, let's...
What's the next match?
I'm getting more used to this.
Honestly?
honestly not gonna lie guys if i just have uh if i just had
my mic setup and everything you know if i just had my mic my
audio setup this would be the perfect pc
this pc would be perfect not gonna lie just i actually i
only need my set up and then we're cooking I have to fly
back with it no I should want to know what my frames are at
this point where is it where is it's been so long since I
looked at this where's the is the video where it shows me
like how many where is it hold up betrays performance
display I need know what my frames are like we're almost
there it's almost perfect guys somehow wraith gets banned up
not looking good that's certainly a development yeah I think
it was 19 cryptos that's pretty fire so crypto is still in
ban still playable yeah we're playing crypto axle like what
the where are these bands good access here unless we get his
own POI alright let's see we are currently 7th right now
Sonny's team has 27 oh this is going to be a long this is
going to be a long day it is this is going to be a long day
no we're going to end in three more games okay oh wait cbx
has 33 get banned and we're good we're almost at matchpoint
cbx they need 17.
yeah pretty close i mean two games are 83 three points wild
yeah those guys are like too locked in right now who are the
roommates no fun no fun on that squad yeah who are their
roommates let me shoot a dm real quick get their paypal i
don't think i don't know if any of them have roommates no
who are their girlfriends who are they living okay who are
their girlfriends let me shoot a dm let's just make them do
a qing game just make them suddenly the wi-fi is out you
know yeah that's weird and ironically crook's internet my
god his internet goes out a lot oh who knows i'm praying for
his internet possible Or boyfriends, yeah, they swing that
way too.
Are you in the lobby here?
There's Sears gold.
Wait, who's their Sear Al?
Do you know who that is?
Who?
Bronzy and Crooks?
Third?
That's senile.
That's, yeah.
Changes his name.
This guy's gold.
He has not touched the game in too long.
There's no way.
He must have played on the side.
Probably not.
No, he's actually gold.
Yeah, probably not It's like it's like riding a bike.
You never forget apex
I mean kind of the game if you the game changes a lot though
But the guns shoot the same way Yeah, no, yeah, you're right
about that.
Yeah So that's fair But these bands are getting a little
weird yeah
A gun's a gun, no matter what.
A crypto ban would have been perfect.
Then we would have been on Raid Seer Watson.
Yeah, that's a god count.
Or if we got an HPR, we would have been on, we would have
been on some fuse.
Some fuse?
Some Raid fuse?
Seer?
Seer fuse.
A Seer fuse, Axel.
Shee.
That would have sounded, that would have sounded nice.
Oh, we're on a, you just should, I forgot.
I'm guessing it's 2-2-2?
Probably, yeah.
Yeah?
2-2-2-2.
We are.
Neon, okay.
Me.
All right.
Um.
What do I think?
Uh.
Place here for sure, no.
Actually, go Watson, Doki.
Go Watson.
Oh my god, okay, okay.
You're so lucky.
I know where Watson is.
Go Maggie, Funk.
As long as I want me dead, I'll just keep on your revenge.
Stay off the grid.
Not in the spotlight.
This could be calm.
We're going to be getting in zone.
Oh, we're playing zone.
And if zone pulls off of us, we are dying.
We are instant dead.
And they're like, it's on the other side of the map.
Yeah, we are.
We are done.
All right.
If you land on this building, loot that and then loot to the
console building.
What are you looting out mid?
I'm looting the east side in the land on this building.
I'm going to loot UAV.
Ooh, got the problem.
All right, last game was a bit unfortunate for me.
There's a sentinel here.
It's all good.
Fierce, uh, serious games don't know what to do after that.
Yeah, we're on the ground.
Zone might be on us.
Got him.
Oh, that's a, that's a good zone.
The zone is 90% on us, actually.
hit that beacon as soon as you can Doki hard blossoms on it
looks like yeah all right I'm coming over to the beacon I'm
zooming up all right ready here we go here we go oh okay to
get up into boardwalk loot what you can just a little bit
like fucking get playable loot and then we gotta go.
I'm ready.
What is considered playable loot?
It's a matter of opinion.
I'm good to go.
Moving.
I'm good.
You want to go through this choke like by bridge or the
other one?
We're gonna go through the high like this one.
Should we have an evoc?
No.
Okay.
Yeah, go through the east choke.
City all rotating already.
There's an evo here too.
Perfect.
Yeah.
I'll grab that evo.
I want to try and get like this building or like the one in
the alley.
I'll start running for it.
How far am I from this?
I think I can reach out.
One 90 from me.
Probably like 180 from you.
I leveled up with my new upgrade.
I shall go electron.
Sure.
I've located the enemy's position.
Yeah, we can get if we can get this building on my page.
we will have an insane game okay i'm gone i think the north
one might be better we need to go kind of soon yeah i think
the north one i think your fucking maggie ball if you want
if it's up it's up but yeah yeah let's go i'm just going in
right side door all right yeah i think this probably should
be right are you going to keep going yeah yeah yeah we got
one of my yellow Nothing.
Next one over.
Yeah.
All right.
I'm in.
We're in.
I have a 2x for one of you if you need it.
Okay.
Um, I'm okay.
Oh, time to start drawing everyone the whole game.
Um, I am 112 with the Phoenix.
I have a 12 flatline car.
I have a blue mag in my car.
I can give it to someone if they need.
I'm good.
Getting them drone.
I'm going to start going for that evo.
That seems great.
Let's see if we can get out of my ground and hold on.
Best spot for Jen.
I actually don't even know.
Probably on the stairs.
Which stairs?
What this?
One that I'm on.
Yeah, definitely.
Here?
All right.
It depends if like the team above us is on Maggie, but I
feel like they probably aren't.
Well, on this thing or on the stairs?
On the stairs.
No one can shoot it.
Like, like, like, like on the platform, I guess.
Yeah, yeah, middle platform.
Yeah, I was gonna say, like on the thing.
That's why I meant on the thing.
Yeah, yeah.
Well, there's no altar, so no one can just queue in on us.
So we should be chilling.
Yeah, no one can kidnap us.
Our only threat is going to be Maggie's.
If this team has a Maggie, that's a problem, but I don't
think they do.
I don't think they do.
There's crypto cats here.
Yeah.
That's what I was most worried about.
We seem to make sure we don't get inted from our southeast.
Like someone could just be a dumbass and just like run it
and just sprint at us.
So I'm going to pay attention to that side.
All right.
These guys are getting imputed.
These guys are getting, like, they have to be low on meds.
They have been getting, like...
Evac coming in from City Hall right now.
Got them.
They look like they're landing for the right builds over
here, like the bank and stuff.
Yeah, they're in the bank here if you want to drill them.
I don't have a drill yet.
I've been just drilling.
I see them next to us.
Making it mad.
I'll chill here.
I'll chill in the corner.
They're crossing the street into our neighboring build now.
ride on their crossing in the middle of the street you're on
a car here uh func you can peek out front you can see i can
see you want me to look at nice hold on good on nice let's
see if you can get them killed without killing yourself i'm
gonna do that i'm gonna emp them just for like i'm running
back a little bit for i almost got the fin i think i can get
it you have drill no i got i got it i got it nice nice it's
a deal now do it now nice i'm gonna work my drone got broken
they can boxerize them though yeah they are right now i'm
going through the window here dorky yeah i'm looking 50.
correct they're full dead they're full dead nice they're
full dead nice it's huge We made him unrecognizable.
Bada Bing.
He kills him.
I'm just 2X wingman right now.
I was just hitting every shot somehow.
I don't even know if it was fucking wrong.
Carry back, Doki.
Yeah, yeah, I know.
Team on the north.
Right here, I'm on the pink.
You can peek them and stuff, Doki, if you want.
Alright.
They're on, like, a really good head, bitch, though.
This guy in this building now.
It's in our south building, guys.
Okay, careful what you're right in the window here.
I'm going to stay here for a little.
Here, take my armor.
Take my armor.
Alright.
Then you can cross.
Just save spots, like, on me.
I feel like I'm surrounded.
Yeah, we're going to be surrounded.
You just play the stairs pretty much the entire time.
You can also peek in here.
In here is fine.
Okay.
Safe where my drone is.
You can play in the bottom floor if you want.
The bottom floor is pretty safe.
He has to be careful of this window.
They're actually queuing across to where those guys died.
We can just maybe get them killed again if we get this
window off.
They can't reinforce this window.
Yeah.
There's a team in our north choke.
They're like wide swing out on the north choke at the truck.
Be careful about that.
Put the unseer.
They're just like, it's like one guy that's like wide
swinging, I think.
It's not looking at us.
He's just like looking down the bridge.
I can see him.
There's a team on my red ping at the tower spot as well now.
so weird i don't want to use all the gen i have another gen
now okay i'll come there's a team coming down bridge right
now there's like a team in that tiny little truck
are we end zone or you have to move later we should be end
up it should literally be the zone we'll hang up okay yeah
so let's just hope nobody wants to breach us don't wonder
nobody's gonna r6 us soon yeah we should be chilling We're
getting droned right now They're imping behind us drone on
my live thing.
It's on your window phone.
Yeah, yeah, yeah It's the parking garage is drone Gildar
door careful careful those don't like sliding across here
now What the fuck?
What the fuck you just ran that shit into a fence?
Yeah, I was like what?
That guy does not know how to fly that drone What the hell?
Yeah, I did not expect.
I was like, what is he going to do?
Run straight to two towards two of my fences?
I guess he does.
Yeah, actually.
That was funny.
I think that's your plat player, maybe.
Maybe your plat.
That might be.
You can reinforce windows and stuff as well.
Like these, you can reinforce them.
I think you already did, but.
or not a plat player.
No, no, I'm plat, I'm plat.
Plats don't know that.
Check my banner, check my banner.
Let me see, let me see.
Oh, triple plat, yeah, you are plat.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You think people would lie in this game, specifically this
tournament?
No, you would never lie.
That's not a thing.
It's gonna be a long day, guys.
I might actually do already messages on.
Yeah, I'm gonna do one message was on my second monitor at
this point on deadlock tendroning for four hours yeah what
the they broke my face it's up looking for kills these guys
are getting like messed with a lot i'm joining this guy on
this corner it's a cost of team in there yeah it cost the
crypto i'm just gonna wait i'm gonna chill here if
we have zone i can break your journey you can place another
one I have I have all I don't want to use it.
Yeah, we're dead center.
Yeah, break the jump.
Alright.
Grab these nades.
Oh my god.
Alright.
I'll grab them.
Round two.
Yeah, grab.
Well, this should pull back to us.
If it goes all the way to the back, that'd be pretty crazy.
But we saw a lot of kills.
It can do that.
It can end right here by the boss.
But we will...
You guys are getting hard into.
really good Joe this guys walked out all the way on my red
bang you only should I don't have fences at the bottom bro
he's like that axle is tweaking bro do you see what he's
doing yeah the backwards slide magnum in the window I only
have 20 wingman bullets so I kind of got a Joe I can give
you my flat line mmm you're like 120 in flat line yeah sure
breaking out of my drone i'm good to go came out of my drone
disoriented as well nah you've been in that shit for too
long you're becoming an ipad kid you're actually getting
brain rot right now you're being us oh no where that came
from i think it came from like to us i think we're fine
we're gonna get into that thing what it's gotta be this
voting i think yeah i don't think it should be possible for
us to get into Oh my gosh.
You're good.
You can reinforce it when the armor is enough.
I just want to get purple here.
It looks like the big jaw.
If you fence across the windows, they'll auto-reinforce.
They'll get broken.
I feel like you tripped the armor.
Hmm?
Yeah?
Tripped the armor.
Sure.
Drop the armor?
Yeah, I did.
I did.
I said sure.
I thought you were just standing there.
No, because I was, it was like muscle memory.
You know how when you, you right click on the big ass armor
shape.
So that was me.
I was like, oh, wait.
Oh, yeah, I forgot it's on the right side now.
I'm taking this guy flesh in here.
He's going to die, I think.
I got bidjo.
I'm going to kill them probably.
Oh, fuck.
You think my arm here?
Okay.
I need the skeletal space over there.
Sure.
See, look, it's a lot faster now.
I mean, we're still in, but we'd have to play bottom, by the
way.
So the problem here?
Okay.
We need this parking garage team to be smart and go fight
with Team Bridge.
These guys.
They need to go fight Bridge.
And then we third it?
Yeah.
They need a rap zone and then we third party it.
It looks like they're going for that.
That's so good for us if they do.
They're going to enter right now.
They're getting thirded as well.
Yeah.
Just don't shoot them.
Don't shoot them.
Let them do that.
Oh, my bad, my bad, my bad.
We play out to here and we kill everything in the low
ground.
We play under the bridge.
Like this shirt, yeah?
Just see your altar drain out.
In the low ground?
Yeah, yeah.
I'm getting ready to walk out out.
Yeah, we should move over now, I think.
You should move over from the right side of you, I think.
Yeah, yeah, go follow.
Follow them, follow them.
Yeah, I'm falling.
We get against the wall, like, under the bridge.
Yeah, in front of me, Axel.
Yeah, right edge, right edge.
Axel.
Cut, pull.
Assel, trying to move into the courtyard.
Gossi point Mosh.
Let's play four.
Kill these guys.
One right.
There's one here, one here on the right.
One here on the right!
Uh, he's literally one.
I'm in the UMP here.
You get by so many enemies right now.
All right, you got you right here right here.
He has one HPV on this.
Nice.
Nade, Q.
Keep it on this.
Nade from above.
Player on me.
If he needs to fall.
I'm going to poke on me as well.
He's going to put him at a layer.
Yeah.
We need to go to funk.
I've just got a newías from the cross.
I'm not gonna go.
I'm under an axle.
I think it is.
Yeah, I'm gonna.
Careful, Funk.
Just stay tucked.
I got him, bro.
I'm ready to meet you.
Stay in knock.
You can pick up all of us.
I'm chilling.
I'm really good.
They're gonna shoot on the side.
Stay in the knock.
I'm trying to...
I got...
I got you a...
I got you a shield in.
I'm lying.
You died.
I could die.
Get her up.
You're gonna try to peek the right.
I could.
I got hit by it.
I'm nice.
Stay in knock.
get doki up let me crawl let me crawl i have to just run you
now i'm sorry i used i mean bro i'm sorry no it's okay it's
all right you can oh man so unfortunate we're just getting
inted bro yeah i there's so many seer attacks yeah it's all
good i just got seer attacked the four times in a row yeah
we need uh seer the ban here really bad it's annoying yeah
it's still a decent game that's an eight that's a lot of
kills yeah what rank what place were they getting at nine
nine points those guys just threw their game they've reaped
us that was so cool it's all good look at that zone pool wow
that's a far pull i felt like i didn't i just felt like i
couldn't move there No, you can't.
Yeah, I was just like, my guns out.
And I'm like, what am I doing here?
Yeah, all I hear is just, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
I'm like, I'm all good.
You know what you can do?
You can't aim.
You literally can't.
It stops your aiming when you get serious.
Yeah, I was just like, hey, I, at least I was there.
Yeah.
You're just in the knockdown over simulated just getting hit
by Syracuse.
It's like, I'm sorry.
I don't know.
happening i'm pressing a button but for some reason no
button is happening like i don't know maybe my mouse is off
i don't know at this point i can't tell if my mouse is like
low battery or i'm just in the seer queue yeah hey that
guy's using an r9 look at that yeah until you see the
prowler in the car okay the team that used the r9 lost like
a little like the r9's like the is gonna make it enough it's
the worst no oh look whose team is top five
is that crooks team yep not looking good
how many games are there left it depends it depends on it's
match point finals so it's whoever You know, whoever hits 50
points and it wins the next game basically So what how many
games?
Yes Oh, could be three honestly.
I mean no one has hit match point yet, but there's two teams
that are close
Yes, yes find him find the invisible boy Yes Oh, yes!
Okay.
The Axel is just gonna rat.
Oh, never mind.
They now know where he is.
They know where the singular rat is.
Oh, maybe this is also a singular rat.
It's 50 points.
That's a lot.
I don't know how many points we have now.
Should we finish watching this game and then we'll check us
in by tab.
you're not gonna get the frames all right rat down right all
right who are you watching now oh they died that's big
that's great news yeah they don't yeah they don't make match
point here they needed 11 they only had three kills they got
like what 53 that's like oh wait no they needed seven
they're far they yeah they need a lot we're gonna be on like
we just got an eight-point error we're yeah that's with 22.
oh gosh okay i'm not gonna win we just need one no we just
need one bro bro we're on oh we're getting better we're only
getting we're only moving up genuinely genuinely you don't
want to be the first team to hit match point because that
team never wins wait really i don't i don't think it's
happened yet where the team that this first hit match point
wins outside of like australia oh my god to collapse all the
talent in australia went to
Oh my god, this crypto has just trolled so bad.
What do you do?
He could have been the Plap Player.
Be nice to him.
Just hit the widest swing of all time into death.
That could have been the Plap Player that sent a drone into
my fences.
Oh my god.
I forgot it was a Plap Player.
Slakes is doing the Lord's work right now.
Yeah, I was gonna say, is that Sykes?
He just like destroyed that guy.
Yeah, Slakes was shooting.
All right, here's the emote, the little bow.
Why didn't we play Seer?
Nike broken.
Yeah, I'm hoping for a crypto ban here.
That'd be very good.
Everyone was on crypto.
Yeah, that would be fantastic.
Or it might be a Seer ban.
We need that badly.
I feel like I saw more Seer.
Bottom Bing might have.
Bottom Bing made a fucking Seer ban, I think.
Actually, no, no, no.
Us and one other team should make it a crypto.
yeah yeah there's a super super team yeah it should be
crypto is it crypto nice it should be i think there was 19
cryptos another yeah there was yeah there's another team on
crypto with no seer as well and another team yeah they did
not play crypto there's not crypto i don't know what to do i
we need crypto i hate playing against crypto get out of here
well macro is crypto so he could actually play the game he
can shoot his gun yeah well just in general crypto is just
such a like character that never oh yeah it's crypto nice
yeah thank god all right i'm playing two now all
right game two complete
game three game three
game four we're about to catch up here though it is a This
is where everything changes, right?
Yeah, we're averaging good points.
Yeah, yeah, it doesn't matter anyway.
It's about the final matchpoint game.
We just have to hit the matchpoint before someone wins.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's see.
Is points updated?
Wait, we're 17.
Not yet, not yet.
No, that's not updated.
Yeah, I was going to see.
Wait, how?
Wait, they messed our points up.
Yeah, I was going to say, why are we 17 points?
No, because I don't even have my kills.
They didn't put my kills in.
Yeah, you might have to say something about that.
Yeah, yeah, I'd be like, hey, where are points at, bro?
They give me...
I had six kills that I gave my thing.
You had six...
Oh, yeah, you did.
You did.
How did they not count that?
And super teams on matchpoint.
I think they messed it up badly.
You said they messed it up right about there.
They got 23, though, Q.
But I don't know if that was...
what they actually got.
Stunny said their points are wrong as well.
Yeah, I'm sure it's going to take them a minute to fix
probably.
All right.
He said, our points are wrong.
We're at matchpoint, so I don't mind though.
That's cool.
Yeah, I was going to say, they're like, oh, I got a
matchpoint.
Might as well take it.
I was going to say, you're 17 points.
I thought we had 20 something.
Yeah, I had like 12 kills, too.
I think they counted wrong.
100% guys Yeah I think I'm pretty sure it just mirrored the
game too Yeah it did So we went up We had three points We
went up three points That game Yeah we went double three
Yeah literally if you go to the game three It literally
mirrored the exact game And that's funny You just copy the
page They're like What more like the guy that was running
this fella sleep on that one game they're like i'll just
copy and paste no actually go ahead to a little copy and
paste people won't notice actually griefing us giving
stunning the match point cannot allow that
let's see refreshing until oh sorry let me
the link uh unpin matt message all right this is the finals
one here i'll pin this one here you guys go maybe they were
the plat player all along yeah yeah guys i swear to god i
got 14 kills there you guys monitored enough when it
happened so guys weren't able to catch it you know just as I
was about to get 14 kills the scores couldn't catch up
there's so many kills the the website couldn't catch up with
it
maybe the real plot players were their friends we made all
along the way oh
my god there's a team with okay I was gonna say it is our
team of three three zero points right now that's possible
thank god that's not i think that's not me they fix it yet
no we're still we're halfway there we're almost there guys
we just need another 20 plus points and we'll be there just
that easy it's 20 more points.
Oh, they fixed it.
Oh, nice.
They fixed it.
Our placement did not change, but they fixed it.
That's good.
It's still the same placement.
That's funny.
It's funny that the placement did not change at all.
But more points.
That's true.
It's starting.
It's starting?
Yeah, we in.
Yeah.
We're on storm point.
Okay.
Wait, what's the comp now?
Probably sear.
It depends on our POI, but probably like a sear axle comp.
See?
What the fuck?
Whoa.
That's a very tiny.
Wait, wait.
The points are actually insanely close.
Let's lock it.
Let's lock.
Come on.
Okay.
We're playing.
Axle.
Are you serious?
Uh, play.
Cava.
What am I playing?
Cat.
Okay.
What am I playing?
All right.
You scared me there.
Dude, I don't know.
Dude, this is like, I have never in my life played from this
POI because this isn't a POI.
I was going to say that's the time.
town I've ever seen on the map we're literally gonna come
out with two cells each yeah funk loot the armor you dokey
loot this building and then the bins here wait we're just
little buildings got these the built the building and the
fucking bins outside of it and then kill that flyer all
right don't let it fly away because you probably scare it if
you land next to it I think I'm gonna fly rash right here
i'll just kill the cnut team doing spiders early some crazy
things kill that fucking thing i get it i have a shotgun
he's dead he's dead he's dead he's dead i only had an eva i
don't know what you want from me i i was doing 10 for pump
look you got it done all right that's that's what happens
good let's go all right so it might be close uh i want to go
mill for our beacon if we can but we can't go too fast We'll
head off them.
Guys, I have an R9.
C-DOT's beacon too.
I got Prowler too though.
I have Prowler and Nemesis.
I'm actually good.
I'm scout Prowler.
I'm kind of chilling with you.
Heavy arsenal too.
Hit this UAV.
There's a Moby here if one of you can grab this before we
leave.
There's a wingman here.
Does anyone want it?
I'm good.
Grabbing the Moby.
Did he say scan already?
I've seen that.
Moving UAV.
Mill looks like they're moving.
Let's go, Mill.
Well, they're playing the other side of it, at least.
I mean, if they haven't hit their console yet, I mean, it
just is what it is, and we're fucking fighting.
Let's see a sight.
I'm fully good.
There's no Evo on them, either, so they can't get blue.
Yeah.
Unless they shot all the prologues down.
I have Axel.
I have 10 shield cells in, anyway.
wants one they look at the about to get on the console yeah
i'm cueing how the do i not see him yet i can see it i can
see it he's on one one oh my god i'm late i'm too far right
on there one far right one far left don't worry i will i
will i'll cue and two you can take my keys I got the thirst.
One is out right, one is in the middle.
Good job.
It's here one, it's here one outside.
I can't swing out right, swing out right, Funk.
Yeah, well.
Go with him, go with him, Doki.
Follow him.
On me, on me.
One is towards the middle somewhere.
Done?
Nice.
The other one's running, running west, I think.
Over here, over here.
I'm gonna try to chase him.
All right.
No, hit console, don't chase.
Hit console, don't chase.
Oh, go.
Careful our bag.
There's an alt Excel.
Here.
It's all you have.
I have one already.
I already have one.
All right.
I'm keep doing it.
There we go.
I've designed the ring's next location and marked it on your
map.
Oh, it's a North Pad Zen.
That's pretty good.
Yeah, that's not bad.
Can we kill the team that was going to be holding us?
Yeah.
I'm going to Evac out front.
Kind of quick upgrade real quick.
I'm going to hit this UAV and then we Evac.
He can't reset anywhere besides checkpoint.
Yeah.
We should be just like, we should just rotate.
We don't even like think about him anymore.
He's out of our heads.
Hey, bro.
Going for the CIV.
Caracidos.
Cido could walk up on us here.
Got him.
Don't have any blues I'm hitting.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
Keep going down bridge.
Go down bridge.
You want me to upgrade?
Where?
No, you got him.
Yeah, just gonna move.
I'm going to QS towards...
Fuck, you have to QS to the left of the rocks.
Yeah, well.
I'm going to shoot us in the back at all time.
I'm queuing us here.
We can probably kill this solo as well if we need to.
Yeah, I think so too.
He's evaking?
Get ready to fry him, I thought.
All right.
Go up.
Back.
99.
One, one, one, one.
Literally one.
Can I hit one in there?
Oh my god, I'm bad.
Nope.
Didn't hit a shot.
Jesus.
flying on the other team to give them the car fuck so all
right and i just took it yeah she moving do you want me to
get hit in spikes or soul peter say soul peter say all right
we hit the cav here and then keep moving surprising very
hard to shoot someone with a prowler when they're on the zip
yeah it's far it's a little difficult guys they're gonna be
right behind us Yeah, they're zipping to our height.
Zipping to our height.
Really, yeah.
There's a path team?
I'm up.
Yeah, I'm pre-putting the Q down.
You just killed them?
I mean, yeah, we can.
I have Axel.
We'll be up here.
You're very alone for a second.
I have Vernading.
Right here.
Vernading?
Good Q, good Q.
I'm sure holding up.
Good Vernading.
Good Vernades, maybe.
Vernading.
It broke zero, but I'm walking.
Axeloted.
100 million.
Double 100 million.
I'm queuing in.
Nice.
fit well 50 flush cut them nice I have you I have you I'm
going to bat I'm batting batting batting batting one splash
heal heal heal they're on the right side go right side wall
I'm queuing into me I'm going to queue into it I'll just
show it two seconds I can't build one right up hold it good
job bro
looking around is is uh P20 good now?
Yeah, it is, but it's like heavily RNG.
Oh, okay.
Like you either insta-kill someone or you just shoot
straight dick and balls out of your gun.
It's just not in between.
It's like you back in this box.
We need it.
Yeah, we can...
The bunkers in front of us were free.
We want to like hold our edge in, I think.
close bunker i'm gonna pop an evac here and then i'll grab
one off the rocks hold on i'm healing i'm gonna hold a movie
amy on purple already you shooting yeah we are i got off
syrians having a field there whoa yeah he's actually gonna
shoot his gun how though how do you have 1400 damage bro
he's Fragging.
You can do that.
We fought two teams.
Nukes.
Those two teams, yeah, all him.
No poke damage entry either, just straight nukes.
Actually.
All right, we can like flex out to this bunker over here.
Just like don't die doing it.
Just like flex out over there.
And then I'll play here and hold our back.
I can play out there.
Doki, go put a spike in here for me.
All right, I ain't no problem.
Nobody's coming through this door.
Put it like in the side of the door so they can't like shoot
it on the wall.
Back in checkpoint.
Like tuck it into the corner.
Alright, nobody's going through this door.
Checkpoint you back, careful.
Yeah, there you go.
And then go do the same thing to the bunker to our north.
This bunker here.
Alright, yeah, I can do that.
But you're gonna put it on both entrances on that.
I just got one tap by a charge rifle.
That is insane.
I'm just coming.
Are you running or?
I'm gonna keep back to you.
It's on the height of an iPad.
They flew far right, by the way.
They might have beacon for third.
Checkpoint two.
All right, okay.
They didn't have third at checkpoint two.
There's a bat here and you need extra bats.
Okay, I have a overflow.
Another evac checkpoint.
I'm just not playing out there anymore.
There's a path set back here.
There's going to be a team coming from Beast.
They're in Beast right now.
Okay.
If you guys want a barrel stabilizer, we know I'm on a no
stage scout, but I've got that red stock.
I have a red.
Do you want red barrel stabilizer?
A red barrel stabilizer?
wait no they're my laser sorry I might I'm not thinking I'm
in the Bahamas I'm in the Bahamas right I see red I was like
that looks like a barrel I they're great they're so great
they're up here yeah one's on low ground he jumped off yeah
is zipping up triple try rocked i don't even know what you
guys are oh i see them top beast don't worry i'm helping out
with my r9 your prowler fucking b20s yeah don't worry i'm
suppressing fire you're gonna see more bullets and they're
gonna get scared it's okay if he's ever in a knockdown we
know what she's winning that yeah they're gonna be backing
and shoot them they're gonna fly probably like just onto us
or like into our bunker nearby yeah we just kill this team
on the landing they can't fly deep enough to like get out of
our range play to stuff them move towards them literally
move towards them while they're flying they're swerving
right back they're swerving two swerves left i'm queuing on
that one one one shot at one i'm killing him i'm smelting up
on them here's close here's close yeah one is split just
fight the bunker yeah i'm gonna fight this year shoot him
i'm swinging i'm getting caught on the side after you after
you see you one on the side yeah i can burn it out you're
gonna get shot on the side nice nice team just can't take
this the other side just peeking over two again one up i'm
gonna go good five minutes out place on path is on me path
is on me grappling with your new deck you traveling i just
noticed it oh bro i'm just getting shot on the side the
whole fight me too i just got two tapped by that triple oh
they're getting thirded right now well i swear i can't break
I literally got thritted right there.
Where's his friend?
I don't think they go far left.
I just had a way better angle.
Yeah.
I wanted to push that person in the bunker and they got shot
on the side.
I think it's this team that shot us from the side, right?
We're getting charged from top high and then there's their
third land to the true defense on.
I See Let me fix
this real quick guys Apparently I've seen a chat box Too
slow Always like right here
Unlucky Unlucky Those did all the I I swear to I I swear
they better.
I hope seer gets the next bad.
I swear to guy.
I cannot I cannot play this I swear I keep getting just I'm
just standing there.
Thank god.
I feel like I'm just standing there yeah it makes the game
pretty hard.
The seers I need like the moment Mac told me that someone's
third fighting I got hit by the seer can you get I feel like
I'm standing mad emoji I'm like okay legit I don't know you
guys saw I had my gun out and I looked at him because I got
yeah I literally looked at him and got hit by the seer
because what can I do what the fuck can I do the standing
mad OG, man.
So, uh, that's 80 a bullet.
Basically.
Yeah, that's 80, 82 a bullet.
Yeah.
I was like, you can see me, but I can't do anything about
it.
He's in the red stuff now.
You just fucked the shit out of him.
I wanted to rush.
I should have just rushed that one guy in the bunker.
So I could have just took that 1v1.
I should have just done it.
I hesitated.
I was just like, I got cracked.
I saw him low HP and I was just like, fuck it.
I'll take that.
It's a godpour.
No.
Oh, that would have been where we would have been, right?
The third party stopped.
Yeah, if we killed this team, we would have had a godspot.
Oh, it's so unlucky.
The third, like, I think after we died, there were two more
third parties, too.
No, it was just a solo ran at them.
Cellar was like third party.
Really?
The Bucky's so, oh yeah.
So there's just a guy like flexing out from the zone.
There's probably this team in the checkpoint bunker.
They probably have like a cellar just flexing out trying to
get KP.
Oh yeah, yeah, because they have to thirst him.
So it wasn't like.
Yeah.
Oh
my.
That's so unlucky.
It's okay.
Maybe Bronzy and them are still, we know that.
Did he die?
I don't think they did.
There's still somewhere in there.
I
just break the axe so we wouldn't lose that.
I feel like, oh, it's max fun to play with.
I like playing with him.
He's a chill guy.
He brings the vibes.
Alright, I'll lock in next game.
I'll focus up this time.
It's just Seer.
I'm not used to playing against Seer.
I think that's my biggest issue.
I'm just not used to playing against seer because like Like
when seer was meta when I last played seriously Like it was
not this bad.
It was I felt like current seer is pretty bad I hate current
seer right now
Yeah current I just my head just needs to wrap around the
fact that I just can't do shit like I'm just I just barely
exist yeah I think that's what's fucking me I think whenever
we're not in a seer game I'm okay whenever the because like
when we did like what when I was on that caustic I did fine
except when I got kidnapped like the seers weren't that
oppressive the seers were so oppressive here.
The slow dude.
God, it's like, what can I do?
They were so oppressive for this game.
It felt like it was just, I was I felt like it just like
crippled my legs.
They actually they like slashed my ankles and I couldn't
stand anymore.
That's how I felt playing against Sears.
it still goes back to seer yeah i think the cooldown is so
short the cooldown is way too short they slash my akele's
heel and then also bash my knees in just to just just to
twist the knife a little deeper you know
what the fuck are people down here
oh my god that was god's wise we won the last third party we
would actually be chilling that would have been our first
place what could have that could have been us we could have
been right there
this could have been us guys we could have been up there
this could have actually been like an 18 kill We had so much
early KP.
This game would have been a massive fucking nuke.
Next game would have been a match point.
Yeah, next game.
I don't know if it is, but...
Oh yeah, next game, I believe.
Next game will be us.
This is us playing it.
I don't know what it is with the prowler.
I can't break Axel.
I don't know why.
Maybe I'm just like not aiming it where I'm used, like,
normally.
Yeah, that team kind of trolled it.
And they just fucking...
like well they did lose a guy they're just like well it's
okay now that sears gone it's gonna be us next game
which points was team noob king on which team was they
weren't last they were in last oh nice so that's about that
one cbx is on matchpoint though
cbx was i oh that's why i didn't care they're already at
matchpoint that makes sense they're already there team
liquid's probably a matchpoint all right panic in them
how many ways do we get i need names on who the that charge
rifle guy was you need two off i need fucking names you
scouting right now yeah man i'm i'm checking the vods i'm
digging in the archives i need to find who the that was
seer band nice yeah let's go let's make it go all right mac
what are we doing let's go um
let me cook i got the dial up my is in my head at the moment
can't buy oh there's only one of them to my match but i sure
i didn't do the math for it just be a cbx yeah we're
literally one way from match one went away and we're good
where we are one one with uh 12 kills i think got this i
believe all right wait one one with 10 kills yeah 10 kills
with one one um i want to say about comp with probably like
an axel or a maggie and then
it's here to depend on poi we're back on world's edge so
maybe not back actually maybe it's a sparrow cat cop
yeah seer is bad thank god i can like breathe for one second
longer thank fucking god i that's so disorienting i
literally i'm just like where am i i felt like i have I feel
like I have Alzheimer's or some shit or
dementia every time he hits me I have dementia and I'm like
where am I wake up from my coat like I wake up from dementia
or Alzheimer's
I'm like oh
what's the current set oh click on the link where's my gun
And Grandpa, you're not in Vietnam no more.
You're out of there.
I'm like, oh, where am I?
That's how I feel right now.
That's how I feel right now playing this tournament.
Yeah.
I don't know who that solo is.
That's just running out there trying to get kills.
Yeah, that was crazy.
just like his team i said must have been like some like
crafting station or some shit to bring him
back they might have just he might have just threw their
whole game honestly i think that's might be what happened
they have nothing to lose at that point yeah true it's okay
guys did you guys know i got two kills oh not just two kills
did you guys know i got four kills oh and calm down
everybody i got four kills calm down uh depending on poi
either a falc axle fuse comp or a sparrow cat naggy comp
come either way we will be util dumping the ever-loving fuck
out of people oh shit we're gonna get a second nuke for this
probably just uh probably just velk velk cat bang maybe valk
cat bang i'm on cat right cat maggie yeah all right i got
you i'm so chill maxing right now guys i'm actually i
actually do feel like i'm in the bahamas right now
I do feel like I'm in the Bahamas.
They're lounging it up.
I'm Bahama maxing.
Yeah.
All right.
Let's see.
More cam.
Yeah, let's play some Valk Axel and Fuse.
What do you want to play?
Wait, I'm on Fuse.
Doki.
play Valk.
Oh, I don't know how to play Valk.
Okay, I'll do it.
No, Axel or Fuse?
Alright.
Oh my God, he's naked now?
He's shirtless now.
On Axel and MNK, you can just do crazy shit.
Okay.
I can do real crazy shit on Fuse.
Alright, guys.
I didn't realize I was muted, but I need to warn you guys,
above me on Valk, might not...
13 kill.
Wasn't able to tell you sooner.
That's okay.
All you're gonna do is take, um...
Yeah, I forgot what side of the perks are on, but when you
get to the left, double left.
Double left?
Okay.
All right, guys.
I'm gonna warn you.
We might need it.
I don't know if I'm gonna get that.
Your fuse had less kills and your fuse was good.
Back up.
It'll be all right.
Wings out Can we hop properly?
No, it's not a monument though.
Or maybe grandma's.
I mean, this could Loki be anywhere.
Yeah, like seeing this.
I opened it a little bit more.
Uh, Loki, I think that we want to go grandmas and go sit on
that building.
Alright.
I think that's our move.
Just loot up and get fucking get going.
I guess.
Wings out.
Here we go.
Prowler creepy one.
There's a...
I'm longbow already 45 right now.
I'll put it in a hemlock.
No sight.
Do you need... Oh yeah, I'll give you the read-a-play.
I don't think I should hold it onto it.
No sight either.
Hit the UAV and then just pop the read-a-play.
You want me to hit this?
Yeah, yeah, hit it.
Okay,
yeah, let's get your grandma's.
There's two high for you.
Pop your V back.
I gave it to you.
Wait, I threw it.
What?
I said you can have it.
Oh, I have it.
I got it.
I'm sorry.
Just pop it.
Pop it.
I said you can have it and I pinged someone.
Oh, I heard that.
I just didn't like process.
I didn't process either.
I'm going to go grab this.
You guys go land all the way over there.
Oh, you want to go right?
Can you cue that guy for me, Doki?
You can cue him while you're flying.
Eat him?
Visual clear.
Good tone.
Oh, I got shot from there.
Just live.
Yeah, I'm gonna live.
I got shot from the right.
Why the fuck?
I can somehow get to East Village.
There's a team in this POI.
You guess?
I don't know what just happened.
They're gonna be caught.
If you have another key, you can key me back.
Five seconds.
Someone's on my head.
I'm just dead.
Oh, no.
There's a full three man on me, bro.
Like, what the?
Oh, no.
No, what happened?
Oh my god, bro.
What happened?
Oh, it's the top zone, dude.
It's the top zone.
No, and we had beacon.
What a tragic zone.
No, I don't even know what happened there.
Everyone was just rotating in and we fucking went against
the flow of the map because we didn't know where zone was.
Oh, so because zone was on us.
Yeah, zone was pointing up to the left or up to the right.
we went down to the left so we ran against the floor the
entire map oh dead for free actually tragic oh we got time
so hard i'm spectating bronzy's team right now so i will
know you know let you guys know they die or not all
right hey maybe maybe valve will be bad
oh that's crazy we got time so hard look a lot remember if i
even looked at the uav i think you hit that uav and then i
started looking for the evac that's something you didn't
know i don't think i even looked at my map because i was
looking for the fucking it's okay if i looked at the map do
you look at the map right um kind of but i mean it was just
like everyone just came out of nowhere they were not I don't
think I think I should land on the Yvonne and then cue it
away Yeah, I was gonna land on it and then knuckle jump out,
but then I fucking took the wrong part I swear to God
knuckle jump was on the left before no, it's on the right.
Yeah, I think I realized that now Yeah, I just took that
shot and I was stuck.
What did you what did you give yourself?
Okay, it's okay.
It's not over yet.
It's not over Tansi's team loses.
It's not over.
I blinked and everyone died.
Yeah, at least, hey, look.
Four other teams also died.
So it's not just us.
You know, if that's the case, we're going to be spectating
this.
I'm going to eat my first meal of the day.
I literally flicked my map open for a second.
You said I dropped the evac and I was like, what the fuck?
And I closed my map and I started looking around for it.
Yeah, because I was like, hey you have actually fried my
brain so bad I I called it too I was like you have the Eve
back I'm not good with this and and I pinged it so that's on
you I even pinged the Eve back all right I'm gonna grab my
food I'll be right back to you all right guys I'm gonna go
heat up my food real quick because I Um, I like literally
just like clocked in and then didn't eat yet, so I'm gonna
grab my food real quick I'll be right back guys
Round two, it's beginning three countdown
Competitor inside, oh damn
Ultimate accelerant here
Matt kit here
here level three my demo here
laser sight here level two
care package being delivered care package over there
standard stock here corrupted t7
scout here
My eyes are glued to this area.
Beginning ring countdown.
Let's go there.
Move your pocket there.
Care package there.
Opponent in sight.
Far off.
Enemy inside down.
That guy there.
Egg there.
Let's smash him.
Round four.
Beginning round two.
Opponent in the distance.
Replicator being delivered.
Enemy here.
I'm
back guys oh I had to I was had to reheat my food got fried
rice got minced garlic with my fried rice and some chili oil
yeah are
you still alive Is that team actually still alive?
Damn.
Can we...
Well, how do I move this mic?
I don't know if you guys can hear me, but it's further away.
My garlic.
My minced garlic and my chili oil.
Need my fried rice to be a little spicy.
I knew it was gonna be a while, so I did not care.
I knew this match would take a while That's why I was just
like Gotta take my time Heating my food You know
We're gonna take my time Make sure the food is nice and warm
Attention The kill leader has been eliminated
I mean if he like I don't know know he can't get the box
anymore so he can't do the box raises so he's got to win
this as a as one guy oh it is good chili sauce I need to ask
them I need to order this back home my first meal of the day
guys got my Lee come key Lee kumki minced garlic the good
shit the good Asian shit right there yeah it's not the usual
um this is I never had these this chili sauce before it's
not like the like old old grandma lady chili sauce um I
don't remember what it's called I forgot the name you know
what I'm talking about the old gram granny chili sauce it's
not that one this is a different one I never had this one
good.
Yeah, Laugan Ma.
That one.
It's not that one.
The one I'm trying out.
Um, technically it's 4pm PSD.
So, um, I'm just having dinner for lunch right now.
Look, if he wins this solo, he deserves the win.
Guys, if he wins this solo, he fucking deserves that shit.
like fuck it
like take that 15k home
I'm like one of these Asians I put minced garlic in
everything I eat it's just so good
really really really really are they fucking stupid oh
they're stupid they're so They No one wants to turn around
At all Not oh really The Watson did all those Fence oh my
god That's a clip right there Oh my god That's That's a clip
right there These guys aren't real They're not real.
Did you see that shit?
Did you guys?
Did you guys see that shit?
That was...
That guy's not real.
He actually could have won us a lot.
I had a feeling, I feel like.
He got behind me.
But he just never saw him ever, so not.
He literally ended in RPOI.
That is insane.
Yeah.
Oh my god, we should have...
Also, Is it me or is Bob like this discord audio just
dropped 50%?
You're better now?
I might have.
Oh my god, I might need to up you.
You're so quiet now.
What happened?
Did my mic change?
Maybe.
Man, who was on the axle on Bronze East team?
Who waited for like a little longer?
You could have won that.
That was correct.
If he was our controller, he probably would have that.
L-Star instant one clip.
Stick out that dropping.
Is Fubb low audio for you guys?
Or is that just...
He is, right?
His audio just got so quiet all of a sudden.
For me.
So let me share.
All good for you?
Hmm.
What the fuck?
it's so low on my on my end for some reason all
right I don't know if it's same for you guys it's fine for
some reason for my end it got so quiet but only him all
right let's see new lobby where
am I there I am No, it's just Mac was the same.
Buzz just suddenly went low for some reason.
I'm double checking if I just suddenly lost here.
On my left ear.
After that absolute disaster of a situation.
We will be playing Watson regardless of who you are.
That's for us.
That was actually fucking tragic.
That's the type of shit that only happens to me when I pick
comps like that.
it's okay you know it's actually crazy you get out of the
way in the creator tournament so it doesn't happen to you at
land surely you know what's actually crazy though if that if
i if fucking that north pack game was a win then we did and
then we got that good thing that did not happen that would
have been extra mode
what two two teams is it matchpoint or is it six games match
point it says match point yeah but they have it set up like
do you see how it's set up yeah like it says group cut off
and it just says one
i'm reading it it just says teams must reach 50 points it
says minimum five minimum of six matches so they can't win
it before like before six games i think what that means is
if that's how it wins it they don't don't play anymore and
they already won and then they play the rest of the six
games out or however many yeah yeah
ninja thank you for the super chat thank you thank you it
was my birthday the other day thank you for being brings me
so much smiles to me over the years thank you for the super
chat ninja and happy birthday happy belated birthday happy
birthday to you happy birthday to you happy birthday dear
ninja happy birthday to you yeah happy birthday i got a
great birthday what's going on with team 19.
if he lives in aria i kind of i kind of doubt it they all
just were in a they were in a pub game oh i was gonna say
what happened to them
i'm yum yum yum i'm always done guys well not um there's
still a lot of fried rice left but all right what's the comp
um yeah max start cooking evoke maggie watson and i'm on
watson let's go
i'm so stupid and i know why perfect poa i know why he was
so quiet for me i'm so stupid i didn't realize the
headphones has audio adjustments and when i took it off i
slid my hand all the way down so that's why i was like he's
so quiet it was me it was me i didn't realize i grazed the
audio like uh volume needle going volume wheel
Weird ass fucking headphones.
Oh, we got a beacon.
Okay, land up here, Lithia's bends.
And Lithia inside and then go to the beacon.
I'm gonna land over here.
I'm gonna land like here.
I'm here.
Or are thermos on probably?
Probably, yeah.
Presettlement, maybe?
Long boat.
All right.
Press the button.
There should be a button on your platform, don't you?
I'm going to press it.
I see it.
Which button?
Oh, you're talking about that.
You're talking about the one on the...
You got it?
Oh, you're talking about that.
I was going to say, you already got it.
Yeah, yeah, I got it.
I got it.
My bad.
I'm sure you grab that power boost, you're fine.
Yeah, I'm going to grab it.
all right i'm actually kind of juiced i have a fully kidded
alternate i just need either power to upgrade this triple
take car pop the balloon on it i'll see you again pops we're
gonna fly down the west edge gonna fly left all right i can
fly over this just follow me oh i'm right i need not to
follow I'm grabbing this here.
Oh, this is not good.
There's a guy on me as well.
Um, they'll end up by Doki.
There's a guy on me.
He's close here.
What the fuck?
On your back.
Pelt.
Dead.
I'm diving.
No one here.
He's running.
He's trying to get out.
Oh, I can't.
On your head, on your head, on your head, on your head.
I got thirst!
I got thirst though.
There was nowhere I could go anyway.
There was nowhere I could go.
I had to try and get the thirst.
Should be good.
They're not just in.
Pharaoh, Cossack.
Maggie.
Survive for us!
I believe!
Craft their staging.
Oh, Mac, are you gonna be okay?
There's... he's over there.
He's running to you.
What the fuck are they doing?
Just a sec.
Healing up.
Hmm.
They're actually trying to run me down.
They need that KPU.
I'll ping them.
They're over here now.
Nobody's taking a redeploy, so...
Oh, there's a team taking a redeploy.
One guy, two taking a redeploy.
They're trying to land on you.
Yeah.
I see them.
Are we fucking for real?
I stopped.
Nice.
Wait, you're...
You're getting this?
Okay.
There was no fucking... Dude.
Are these motherfuckers real?
I was gonna say, I don't think you should have done that.
I think you should live for your life.
They're actually gonna fly on you, I think.
Yeah, they're flying on you now.
That might have been a little bit too hell-mary
They're flying just assume they're flying just assume
they're chasing you
Like at that point just assume they're in here
Like I don't even think really you were going to try to res
me there.
Why is my gun bright?
Like, why do I have a flashlight in my eyes?
Oh, it was girls' team.
I think they saw you pivot to me, and they're like, we gotta
chase him now.
Oh my god.
Holy fuck.
That's crazy that they chased us.
What happened there, though?
I mean, the team Fissure just shouldn't be...
Like, the mod team, which is them, just shouldn't be doing
what they're doing, but they did.
Yeah, yeah.
They should just be rotating.
Also, they were like...
They just stayed there too long.
They just ran with the Evo and just stayed there, yeah.
And it just shuts down the whole middle of the map, so you
get punished for it.
Oh, I see.
I see.
It's not...
It's not on us, it's just teams being stupid, basically.
Pretty much, yeah, pretty much.
It's just, you might have played a little too aggressive or
some shit, right?
That POI is just like a hard-rotate POI.
Like, normally they just, like, land and just leave.
I see.
Because I'm, like, going for that EVO.
Yeah, yeah.
The south zone just doesn't, like, normally happen ever.
Okay, so as long as Team Liquid and CPS, Don't win.
We're still five.
We're still here for another game
That's unlucky.
Yeah Oh my god, they came back ate my fried rice and back at
it again, I guess I
We're back it's waiting we're back to watching the game
again
True more time to eat my fried rice
so true
the team that the team that we killed like we landed on died
right guys right
yeah this team this team died yeah yeah this was the
pathfinder team I killed
this is a watch true this is a watch along the stream yeah
we got the KP at least that's all We got we got the KB.
I had most damage.
Let's go.
This is the first time guys The first time you see me with
the most damage on the team
This is a rare moment Let's go.
Wow, I got more damage than two pro plays What the fuck
Hello?
What the fuck?
What fucking rank are they?
It's their team name.
Oh, they need, never mind, they need these.
They actually need it.
They're like...
Oh, this is a good... Yeah, they're like 12th place before.
They actually needed this.
They actually needed this game.
Oh, you're down.
Hey!
damage is damage guys that's why people thirst chat
thirsting pads damage damage is damage
oh my god that guy has five kills yeah
and also i was thirsting for kp guys uh i was thirsting for
kp Not because I was padding my damage.
Let's try to make sure we have the KP.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, what?
Oh, that was going to save.
Oh, they're going to...
Oh, the random breach charge.
That's crazy.
I think they win this fight, though.
Yeah, they should.
Like, that team has to run.
Oh, and let...
Oh, what?
Oh, they're a resident.
Oh, they're sticking their eyes too.
What the fuck is going on here?
Oh, they're detonating.
They're Bangalore.
Okay, they're banging.
There's no way.
Do they live that?
Oh, they do.
Why didn't it take advantage of them?
Oh, they just wanted to leave.
They don't care.
Oh, no.
Because there was another team, they actually do care.
there was another team they did care they got scared
oh my god what the fuck is going out this that's oh they
have to read a play i i don't know what's going on
wait they didn't even challenge him they just oh my god
skins people are oh now they don't want to push Oh, now
people want to be fucking pussies about it.
I guess I fucking guess Now no one wants to push anything
Wow, I'm making it everyone wants to be a fucking pussy I
guess No, this guy this team wins that but there's no way I
was like, there's no way this team loses that
It's not fair.
I don't get it.
When we get...
When we see a team, everybody pushes us.
When they see a team, no one wants to push them.
Fuck me, I guess.
Are we winning?
Yeah, this is me right now.
I'm top 12.
Seven kills.
I don't know.
That's me.
Yeah, I got seven kills.
Pretty neat.
You wanna see me get an eighth kill?
Oh, he, sorry.
Sorry, I missed the...
Sorry, I don't play Sparrow though.
I missed the queue.
But don't worry, I won't miss the second time.
Watch this.
Sorry, there's a cooldown.
Give me a sec.
I have a cooldown.
Oh, yeah, you see that?
Watch, see?
Boom.
Told you I won't miss a second time.
Let's go see what's up over there.
Yeah, it's my, you see me, see my mouse drifting is the
mouse drift, you know?
It's like controller drifting, but like I simulate, I
simulate controller drifting just to like, uh, give myself
aim assist, you know, just to trick the system into giving
me aim assist.
That's why you see the controller drift, drift.
But I am on mouse and keyboard.
the fame yep the really advanced tricks that mk players do
where they simulate a controller chip and it tricks the game
into into giving you aim assist because they thought you
were you're on controller controller guys i'm a little
worried i haven't seen team liquid or or the other team cpx
die well i'm a little worried guys
I know twice in a row we landed on a team how lucky can you
get with that heck how lucky can you get with that rotation
twice in a row we landed on someone while rotating
like we had the best games of our lives and then we used it
all up we literally used up all our luck to qualify
That's crazy.
Just to call.
This is, these are the matches that matter.
Well, Team Liquid and CVX are around here.
We need girls team to win this game.
If they're gonna run me down like that, they better win the
goddamn game.
bro they guys had the phrase walkings of every team yeah
they did they got they got jumped out by two different teams
and they both ignored them both teams ignored them just to
rotate i was like what the fuck oh but when we want to
rotate we get fucking shot at by 20 teams yeah the teams
don't even want to get killed boys they just want to fucking
rotate the fatigue oh my god it's been five hours it's
setting in guys fatigue setting in right now oh man i don't
know how players do this i don't know how they do this five
hours in you know it's crazy i could play arrivals for five
more hours if i could pass that 12 hour mark by kid i think
it's because like it's apex there's a lot of downtime too
when you're knocked out I can't for in the tournament I
can't just re-queue you know I can't just re-queue I have oh
CBX guns but there's still Timu liquid CBX down I'm a little
bit worried about the though.
They didn't die, right?
I didn't see them die.
This might be them.
You recognize the skins?
No, I'm just assuming.
Damn.
It's like you don't want to try.
Oh, that was them!
Oh my god.
They did it.
They saved the game.
oh they that has to they were like but ranked below us too
that should give them like a juicer how many kills do their
teammates have okay it's just one guy getting everything
he's just like you the sparrows basically fuck I'm
washed what
Is this two full teams?
Wait, everyone.
It's one rat in that pit.
Yeah.
He might actually live.
He's just chilling over there.
He's letting that rat live.
Oh, that was embarrassing.
Alright, rat time.
This is rat going to 1v3.
Let's see.
Oh!
Oh, that was close, that was close.
Who is that rat?
Oh, they're a little too close.
Yeah.
What gun was he holding?
We have our apex champions.
A little too close to comfort.
All right, game six.
Wait, game seven.
Wait, I've already lost track.
What game are we on now?
I've lost count.
I don't even know what game we're on, guys.
Oh, we're on game seven.
Oh, my God, we're on game seven.
Give it up for game seven.
How do you guys do this?
How do you guys...
How do you guys play more than six games?
It's crazy.
Yeah, it's hell sometimes.
Played 13 games one.
I played 13 games before.
oh my god 13 games mm-hmm it was like nine hours nine hours
some like that what was it what land was it for it the first
EWC land oh my god I think it was 13 right or was it 11 I
don't remember that's crazy oh it was a we just had apples
and bananas how many teams were how many teams were made it
made it to Cut match point.
I don't remember a lot.
Maybe like.
8, 9 to 10 probably.
Jesus Christ.
I don't remember exactly.
I hope we get less or more.
You know what?
I hope we hit 13 games today.
I don't know.
I don't hope we hit 13.
I already hit the better.
I hope we hit 13 games.
close this out on the next two dude i just ads with a 250
car skin and it flashbanged me i am checked no that was
actually crazy i'm not gonna lie that just blinded the hell
out of me i'm never using this again oh so we are mad maggie
is banned now wait didn't and they keep banning legends
right so like yeah does it not it doesn't reset or anything
right only if the characters that slot like control errors
yeah oh that's crazy i hope oh we're gonna see some crazy
shit we were actually no controller so period i hope we see
some mirages in the fight all right please god don't please
don't we might have to get a mirage here i got fucked by one
mirage already today please don't yeah but then we'll be the
mirage player it'll be different because we'll be playing
mirage
think about it just imagine all right what's the cop uh
Watson something
probably I mean like all the good skirmishes are banned so
probably gonna be like a bang or a Valc with Watson oh
there's three teams on four wait there's five teams on
matchpoint yeah we're gonna make it the six six six of them
oh wait i didn't see it above he has six teams yeah i didn't
see it either guys we're gonna be the seventh team guys this
is it we might just have to play a kill comment this point
oh yeah just called it a just like yeah maximum one yeah
just don't sit in zone like i mean if you're walking in for
free like that that is getting empty i have never seen
someone walking out there when they're like that how are we
doing this um it really is just gonna depend on the poi that
it flips flips us into probably like probably a fuse comp
with Valk probably like Valk fuse maybe like a could be like
a little cat sparrow little cat sparrow fuse baby comp
Maggie is gone actually am I speaking on baby comp here no
but I don't know if it would work I'm not gonna lie I don't
I want to say it wouldn't we could play cat gibby fuse we
could maybe a V in a lobby like this makes me know nervous,
I'm not going to lie.
You could just go UAV, UAV, and just fight before.
Yeah, it could probably Valkyrie fuse.
I believe.
You're cooking, you're cooking.
Guys, if we last another game, I think Timmy has to legally
leave.
So then that's one less team to worry about.
Here he left.
Oh, here he left?
Oh, I didn't even realized which team was even on as soon as
you said it team 10 as soon as you said it i just clocked it
oh he's already gone yeah because apparently yeah i saw you
it was like i need to go to a sponsor i don't fucking care
guys like he's just like i'm clocking out that soon as it's
almost five what team was eon i don't even remember their
team names zach and rogue yeah Yeah, but their team name.
Mouth and key, I think.
That makes sense.
Did he already leave?
Yeah, he already left.
Red Lotus.
Ooh.
Okay.
Yeah, we could have outgiven Fuse.
What am I on?
Man, Watson's still available.
We can buy whatever you're feeling now.
Well, no, I'm just worried about Watson existing.
We can play Sparrow.
Play some Fuse.
where am i on valk all right here we go
take take two i believe all right if we just get it you're
always game we're gonna live if we die because the zone
pulls on our head i'm gonna be so sad guys if we die because
of my valkald i'm i will apologize in advance right now
you're gonna do so great i remember outcome before in the
tournament.
Nah, no, you're good.
You're good.
Luke, that's moving from the bottom up, Ducky.
I just I'll be controlling the plate.
Oh, this is bad.
No, no, no.
You're fine.
We can split off.
Okay, you guys have to split off.
No, you guys have to split off.
I don't know how to dolphin properly.
You're fine.
No one need to be like...
No, you're good.
Don't worry about it.
Yeah, yeah.
Zones on our head again.
Which it might be, like, over here.
So it's...
I don't know, this has been pretty unlucky.
Don't worry, our luck changes around.
There's no way it goes four in a row.
Surely.
Wings up.
Up I go.
Am I just trying to triple take the game?
I feel like this gun's good.
You did good with it.
It's not bad.
I'm just gonna try it.
I don't really have the ideal setup right now.
Honestly.
I'm sentinel car also not looking good.
Alternator havoc.
We got a lot to loot.
What the?
Yeah.
We really are not looking.
Wait, what are you on?
Maybe alternator havoc because that's all I could find.
We have a heavy arsenal in RPOS.
We can grab some stuff there.
See, says not too bad.
Maggie's got the lead.
No, I think it's good.
Oh, guys, I got an R9!
No, no, no, no.
Hey, guys, our looks changing.
It looks changing.
I got an R9.
Sniper stock for your...
That's insane unless he takes...
Oh, wait, do you want me to use it now?
Yeah, you can hit the other.
Check the map.
Check the map, this time.
We'll take the thing to get more powerful.
We're gonna go east and grab less.
Come.
We're just gonna work like the east side of the map and then
go towards the middle.
We'll grab that even and then path down to the next turn.
Imagine crashing and burning on takeoff.
I think the blue, should I take the jump perk?
Up to you.
I'm my low key.
Just like an angle a lot of stuff this game and get a lot of
free kills maybe?
Yeah.
Crafting over here.
Wings out.
All right.
looks like there's some baby comps give eval is that gonna
be a really good comp yeah baby comps will get nuked by us
even if i have the other blue perk oh no the other one is
better for killing baby what am i supposed to get left the
scan one okay alright guys guys we have I have flatline now
I'm being fucking flown out right now I'm coming back
they're looking for the eva so baby can try to get here
rampart rampart rampart give me on how to so far from two on
that advantage bro careful careful i need to wait for this
mark to go away hunter bang nice i'm with you i'm coming
back to you i think they're backing up on the bridge
advantage could be mirage i think they're gonna aid us here
the advantage and fucking Narnia.
One's close.
Close.
Close on us.
A bubbed.
Nice.
He's up.
He hit the zap.
He hit him already though.
He's dead.
I sent one twice.
We're gonna go through it.
He bubbled a minute with it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He definitely bub.
Come, come, come, come.
I'm with you.
I'm eating his up.
New team, new team, new team.
We're aiming on that.
We're aiming.
Yeah.
I agree, bro.
What?
I just got here.
I should have stayed.
The Valky's chasing from Bridge.
You're gonna die here, yeah.
No, don't make me spectate.
Don't make me spectate another game, fuck.
Fuck, don't make me spectate another game!
Oh my god, I'm out.
I swear, don't make me spectate another game.
Don't make me spectate another game, fuck.
Oh my god.
Can you bleed out?
I can rest both of you.
I'm trying to.
Nobody wants to thirst me.
Why am I getting sprinted at by a Vantage Sparrow Gibby?
It could be the same.
It could be girl again.
I hope to God it's not.
Otherwise I'm going to want to fight my roommate and he's a
lot bigger than me.
I don't want to have to do that.
Oh no!
No!
I can't!
Don't do...
I'm moving.
Don't do this.
to me don't do it is don't make me watch another game don't
make me watch another game i can't i can't watch another
game i might leave no you can't leave you're our carry you
can't leave like actually i don't think so don't don't do no
there's a there's a crafter lotus i'm actually resetting you
lock in just full reset yeah there's a god team right here
i'm literally gonna hide our bodies somewhere oh i was
moving out we don't know i wanted too many teams out here
what is happening okay i hit my body i hit my body there's
no way they'll find it Nice, nice, nice.
Full reset coming in.
Oh my god, thank god.
I don't want to watch another one.
I...
Oh, thank god.
Can't watch another game.
We have to win this one.
I can't watch another one.
We have to.
Bada Bing and Mad Boring.
One of those two were the ones that ran at us.
Don't bring me back.
Don't bring me back to that, to watching, to spectating.
We're back.
No more spectating.
Okay.
We haven't been able to get out of our goddamn POI the last
three years.
I just...
Yeah, I don't know what the fuck is going on, dude.
Dude, I'm actually freaking out.
I'm going back for my body.
No shot.
You want to go back over there?
It should be fine now, right?
Sure really.
There was a fight.
There was a fight there last time.
What a babycom team.
There's no UAVs nearby.
It should be fine.
I swear to God, Mac.
I swear to God.
Okay, look.
If Galleria hits their UAV and Evac's in the gas at us, I
mean, fair play to them.
You know, they just want it more.
Sweet again, Matt.
Granted, that already did happen once this game, but what
are the odds of it happening twice?
Yes.
Oh my God.
I just heard some shots.
They are still fighting on the edge of zone over here.
We might just get a third party.
You got to think about they're fucking fighting.
We're getting in some ass.
We're third partying this shit.
Get into this.
I'm about to queue into it.
They're in Galleria, like in the choke.
Yeah, yeah, I see out there.
I only I have my last syringe.
Popping a meta here.
How many are in?
I should I go for my loot box.
Yeah, go grab your box.
Okay, I'm grabbing my box.
Close up.
One's up top.
I'm high.
Castle.
We can shoot this guy.
Come to me.
Can't move.
Valk, bro.
The timing is insane.
I'm going to shoot the Valk in a second.
Castle's still right here.
I'm not kidding.
Shooting Valk.
They're stuck in the corner.
Left corner.
Castle right here.
Castle cracked.
I confused with the corner.
Fused with the bump.
point error a day they're gonna go castles on his attack
here if you have nades they're gonna go up i have nades i
know he's wearing i have q wait bubble's gonna drop they
can't buckle look at the castle i'm getting finned okay
you're right there's another team across yeah can't get the
first because you gotta just lose i can't use all that i
can't use all that okay i don't have it i thought yeah
there's team shooting right where we go
97.
Yeah, let's just Valhalla.
I don't know.
It's just Valhalla.
Just pull our Valhalla here if you got it.
Right here?
Yeah.
Maybe I get off a little bit later.
All right, remember to piece off.
We're going up and over to like my yellow thing.
All right, you guys got a piece off.
It's not smart.
Yeah, I'm fine.
I can't land short.
Land short.
short grab the sieva okay and then we can we can hit that
uav too and we can walk into the spot that i think just hold
our gallery around come out i'm holding our back i'm holding
the bag i'm gonna sit on it yeah doki come hit this uav okay
i'll walk it off i only have one rest and someone else just
rest in fucking lotus i got it i got a back hole the back
hole energy group yeah just walk for him
I have zero flesh mods.
I can't.
I have six.
Okay, I'm dropping you three and just...
Thank you, that's all I need.
Oh, look at that movement there.
I think the way I actually clicked this one because I was
kind of hesitating.
But as soon as we got landed on it, it's okay.
Two flags here.
I'm not looking at the shells.
Oh my god, we're in God's spot.
We just got caught.
Okay.
Hey, attention to this choke.
Can anyone go over here?
I'm...
No.
What?
Yeah, they're fighting on the other side of that choke.
The red ping.
Overflow here for one of you.
If they fight, we can 3P it.
Should I look behind us or no?
I think they're fighting the gas.
Give me that power booster and then take the overflow.
We're still...
Oh, they're over there.
Dibs.
I'm looking with funk at this.
Wings up.
I don't hear anything right now.
The team comes through e-bank.
We just want to kill anyone that comes through e-bank, so I
don't know.
if you can.
They're box resina.
Oh, like, Spirit 160 above.
On the other side of this box.
Let's look at that.
You want me to come over?
That's clear.
Yeah, yeah.
Almost.
I can fuse with the fuck out of this.
They're path-sipping out of zone.
What the fuck?
There's a team that was bubbles on what?
Grabbing at us.
On the right.
On the right wall.
Cue it on.
One, one, one.
Five, five, man.
Look at the next team.
They're in gas as well.
In the building here, under them.
I'm just holding the climb up, okay?
One is in here.
He's on the back door.
I could see the line.
Another team is resing in gas deep over here.
Yeah, Bruce.
Yeah, they're boxers in the building.
In the building?
I see them, yeah, yeah.
10 seconds on down, though.
10 seconds on down.
They're probably going to go back up.
Yeah, back up here.
The vocal thing?
I'm going to ice wall.
I'm going back to ice wall.
Shooting him out of the air.
Okay, they went over the wall.
Yeah, I'm looking for them.
You're going deep.
I'm going back to the spot.
I can fuck them if they land shore here.
Or they did.
They went low gun.
What did those Pathfinder's box go?
No idea.
Should be on your left over there.
So probably on the other side over here.
Yeah, that's whatever.
I'm looking for already on the street.
I'm 4-4.
I can drop bats.
I'm 5-10.
I'm alright.
I was just going to look for attachments.
Can you drop me some cells for over for that?
I have a lot of cells.
Yeah.
there should be good now what the is that is this the baby
come to him that is behind us 140 on castle i'll be able to
ult him i got some i got some really good really good oh
they have to move got their bob i'm gonna fuck them again
i'm gonna have old again okay you guys is like left side
though five seconds yeah we're getting we just got a spare
with it from the left yeah you need to come back you need to
come back up yeah I'm gonna bubble out.
There's a Gibby out.
I'm trying to hold you.
Sure, I got it.
Oh, this left of the wrap is so good, but...
Yeah, we need to...
I mean, I definitely want to play for the left, just play
into the boss.
Alright.
It's like a Sparrow fucking fuse or something like that.
Sparrow Watson.
I'm gonna keep fucking with this Gibby team on the right.
What do you want me to look at?
Uh, you kind of need to bully this team over here on the
left, the Sparrow.
Okay.
This is...
is fucking this is jelly in them over here okay that's a
matchpoint team i hope there's no team behind us that's what
i'm one's on the car here do we have verts yeah they're bang
sparrow watson he's off the car he's off the car just
playing here i see them now you're not a bank 120 on bank
you need to just apply pressure to the baby comp team i
think okay no no no apply pressure to the bank the baby comp
team give you a hold like in their wall
But you can do it from right here, Fung.
You can see the top of their wall.
It doesn't get zapped.
I did it.
Where do we go?
I just got stunned.
Oh, shit.
I'm telling.
I just got stunned in my queue.
Yeah, we just want to keep bullying this team.
Yeah, I'm going to keep killing one.
We got another spot.
Yeah.
Castle 50.
Castle 120.
We just need to get their wall one is unenergized.
They're...
I'm going to try to burn anyone.
Carry your left, guys.
Yeah, I'm good on me.
You can otherwise left on me.
Blinding guys, two teams.
It's gonna make it weird.
I might even be able to shoot them.
I'll have them land on people.
Okay.
You're perma safe in the bus on me, by the way.
Okay, I'll go, boys.
Joki, you can sit in here and literally just stare at this
team.
I stare at him?
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, from inside, like from the glass.
Alright.
Just be careful.
There's windows and shutters.
Yeah, yeah.
This guy's got cracked.
Bro, I'm about to abort again.
I'm about to abort at 20%.
I'm like, you're like, get a name out of it.
castle.
No, I can't.
Nope.
They're getting pinched.
They're gonna pinch right now, I think.
Surely someone's on the staircase.
Yeah, we need to play for that right side.
This team's gonna mirror us.
Yeah.
You really want to shoot me.
They're leaving.
They're looking at the staircase now.
Can we kill this team?
Yeah, we can try.
I have Fuzel.
I think we should, I think we should play this team because
they're just gonna mirror us a little bit more of it.
Oh wait, Fuzel needs to heal.
I can Fuzel.
Yeah, Fuzel's on them.
Fuzel's behind the bar.
I'll do a breach there because they're Watson.
I'm fucking them.
20 on, 40 on all of them.
Above here.
They think I wasorkin.
You're along.
We're talking about Jed.
Come on up.
We welcome them.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
I throw my, I throw my two.
Flash.
One of his flesh.
They ran somewhere.
Play down a layer.
Play down a layer to me.
Follow me guys!
They're fighting on a bridge.
Following me.
Follow me.
You're alone a little bit.
Yeah, we need to kill this.
They just wiped it under the bridge.
They're resetting right now.
We just need to run at this.
Yeah, we're coming.
I'm bubbling on this.
With you.
Bang cracked.
Bang cracked on the left.
I'm with you on the right.
Look at the Watson.
Bang is on the left still.
Bang one.
Bang one's up.
Back above.
20, 20.
Come on, come on.
I'm getting fens.
Getting fens.
I got fens.
We're gonna go back to where we were.
That's the spot that we're playing.
No problem.
Okay.
Run back.
On our right, new castle team.
We can fuck them for me.
We're really good on me.
Really good on me.
Okay.
We can hard angle them.
Yeah, we have a permanent safe corner here.
If we break that wall, it's really good.
Hey, careful.
I'm going to slowly break the right side of the wall.
Shots above us.
I'm going to make sure we don't get robbed from height.
Yeah, go ahead.
I have no option.
I need cells, guys.
I have cells.
I have cells here.
Thank you.
Just want to make sure this team doesn't bubble.
There's more cells here than you.
Okay, I'll grab some more.
in a second just trying to pressure these guys off i'm gonna
try to walk
up the ramp here and peek and see what's going on okay
there's a full three man in this corner here we need to just
play the low ground as long as we can okay i have to this
right team out there i feel like yeah we do this ain't my
zapier they're going in my bubble up top we're good we're
good Okay.
I mean, I can give you out the bubble.
I can fuse with the bubble.
No, no, no.
They have a, they have a castle wall and a safe point.
We just need to play into this wall if you're late.
Look right.
Look, what's happening right.
They're fighting right.
Yeah, I'm with you.
Can we wrap this?
I don't think they're hard.
They're not hard fighting.
They're not fighting.
They're just sitting.
Should I come back?
Go back?
Yeah, yeah, just try.
Yeah, just hold our back, okay.
I gotta give you a lot of them.
That's really good.
Yeah, that's good.
Are there any fans?
I'm gonna, I'm gonna fuse with the bubble.
Yeah, yeah, if you let me come over or no.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I give you all the time so they can't slide down in the last
place.
Yeah, let's walk up.
Let's walk up.
We're not holding a 40.
My Gibby's not hitting anything.
They have talk.
They have talk down.
I have no Gibby.
I have one Gibby.
I'd hit them all at that.
No talk anymore?
Just hold.
You're like right here.
I wish I'd have to wait for the roof to be out before we can
play up into our ramp.
Like we have to like play to this wall.
You see my ping?
Yeah.
Yes, I see how it's yeah.
A hell of a discipline.
You might be able to play that really.
I'm about it.
I'm about to the spot.
Go to the spot.
Don't look right!
Okay.
Just keep close left actually.
Focus left.
I'm gonna let him come over here.
I need a shot.
I need a heal, I need heal.
Wait, I need a focus left.
Boilie, I'm melee.
I'm kneeling.
I need a defusal.
No, I need a defusal!
No, no, no, he's on the team hunt.
In a bubble, in a bubble, in a bubble!
I need him!
Keep it cracked!
He's crap.
Otherwise...
I cried!
Oh, the other guy's cracked too.
Oh, I didn't see them eat the zap.
Oh, I guess.
Why were those guys just...
Oh, my God, bro.
Oh.
Did you freeze all at the right?
Yeah, because I thought they were just going to angle us.
They like set up a new wall and they could just fucking
swing us for free.
Oh, CBX is eliminated.
Oh, wait.
I don't even know who the other teams are in match point.
Oh, who's this?
Who's this one?
Jelly Hunt.
It's up there when the game is over.
This team?
Wait, Jelly and them are going to win.
Oh, wait, Jelly and them won.
They won.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, they won!
They actually just had one really good game and then they
closed out.
That has to be a solo, right?
Oh, they're...
Yeah, no, they're... Yeah, they won.
It's over.
Wait, what the fuck?
What happened?
Like, what happened?
They went to Baby Gump.
What the fuck just happened?
Oh, that was a crazy game anyways.
Yeah.
we might we have to be top 10 right from that this was the
only team that could have won that game yeah maybe uh four
kills oh my god that one game solidified everything for them
hey we broke they broke bronzy streak though they did yeah
yeah they've broke the streak from bronzy and that's all
that matters and the best part insane those three games in a
row about yeah the back i think if we didn't get if we
didn't fucking land on people three games in a row that
would have been yeah that was insane hey but we qualified
this time mac we ran it back and we actually qualified into
this second round yeah we did we did actually make it
further progress it's progress yeah it can always it can
only go up yeah we literally didn't qualify the last
tournament by one point that's crazy let's see if we get top
10 how many kills did we have do you get paid for top 10 or
something i don't know i'm pretty sure you get paid no
matter what do we not not from the last one oh was it not
the last one was it top five or something weird he he
doesn't make funnels in the last one yeah yeah well yeah
that's pretty true actually and there was like 40 plus teams
too last time so i was like i don't think oh we have 11
almost top 10 plus one nearly nearly but not bad not bad if
we got that north fad game we actually would have been
chilling we would have been top 10 yeah we finished no
finished like top three with that north side game probably
top four top four yeah we probably would have played a ring
con the next game if we won that north side game to be
honest probably yeah because we would have been on match
point yeah i think we did pretty you know what despite
having three rough games i think we did all right we i agree
yeah it was a solid such it was a solid such a solid for the
invite i appreciate it yeah thanks for joining us thank you
thank you ggs guys oh is that your roommate have a great is
that yeah he's in there hyping him up yeah not thinking
that's his roommate fucking rubbing it in his face no
actually bro i've been like get the out bro i would have
unplugged his he should have unplugged his pc he should
that's on him i would have done that game i didn't unplugged
it just ran in room and just unplug and just be like we're
gonna play another game bro we're game eight let's go you
know second place in semis hey we'll take that we got second
place in the first round and that was us around not too bad
maybe that's why maybe that's what went wrong in this half
what maybe there wasn't enough around maybe we should make
true i mean when we were technically on the last game we
were technically sort of fucking around and then we made it
to we were like what we were uh 1 2 3 4 5 6 plays they are
on the last game we didn't have to spectate
props for props for fought for not making us spectate the
last game thank fucking god I would have been so fucking sad
I would have been fucking awful that would have like please
don't do this to me i can't i cannot spectate another game
back to back 100 clutched it washed my ass
all right ggs guys ggs have a good night a good day not a
great time let me play me too me too farewell i hope we get
to play together again guys of course of course and we
should run it back Yeah, if there's another one, just let it
run it back unless you guys get recruited by bronzie, then
I'd understand, you know I'd understand you guys want to
join bronzie's team instead of my team No, we don't, we
don't We don't We don't, we don't You guys are fraud I Yeah,
they didn't get first They didn't get first That's true,
that's true, girl broke his streak Alright, I'll talk to you
guys Later Goodbye, goodbye Have a nice cheese that was fun
guys that was fun but not i'm proud of you but not like a
parent happy audio thank you for super chat thank you thank
you we did guys maybe i should not have used the r9 maybe
maybe i should have pulled out the r9 maybe every time i
think it was like the siren chris I think every time I had
the R9 in my hands, like we have a, we, we like have a bad
placement.
It was a cursed item.
It really is.
Every time I had the R9 in my hands, we had bad placement.
I, I should have, I should have got, I should have pulled
out the flat line first.
Couldn't resist the siren call.
I should have pulled out the flatline.
I don't think we would have lived even if I got that guy
down.
Just because of how, like, we got, they got thirded
immediately, right?
Right after.
I think we did pretty well.
For, uh, we made, I mean, we made it to the finals.
We called for the finals.
And we got second place.
we got second place in the finals in the semis um and i
think we placed pretty well um we were in the middle of the
pack and that's you know middle of the pack not not last
place but in the middle and we had three really really bad
games to and but we were still in the middle and that's what
counts despite having three really really bad games we still
we still did pretty well I mean we're like what 14 points
away from matchpoint anyway so I think you know
I think I think we were we did pretty decent and there were
some really good teams that are below us too so you know
what I'll take that I take those oh my god Zara's team is so
fucking oh my god that's that's a loophole team right there
Zara's team was definitely a loophole team anyway I'm gonna
call here um I hope you guys had fun watching I have always
had fun hanging out with you guys and streaming for you guys
I am sort of back but I will be coming home going home
tomorrow actually going home tomorrow for real not not just
breaking into somebody's place and be like hey I didn't use
your PC for my sponsor tournaments while we coming back home
tomorrow so no streams tomorrow i'm gonna figure out my
schedule for for a bit all right guys as always everybody
stay hydrated posh check you up and move around and get that
blood flowing stand for me head to bed because you deserve
it check out the people that were on my team alberolay which
is mac and fun um check out the people sorry i was like i
had to like i was trying to click on their channel but yeah
check them out their channels are in the Give them some
love, because Mac has always been a homie.
He's a bro.
He literally ditched his team just to be part of my team.
And the team he ditched ended up not qualifying.
So, you know.
Hey, you know.
We did it.
Hey, guys.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.